welcome welcome to West area plumbing my
name is Mark Cargill and chairing the
meeting this evening person housekeeping
there are no fire alarm scheduled this
evening so if you do hear an alarm
please treat it as a real alarm and meet
outside it's in the carpark down by the
side of the windmill pub please note
this is a planning meeting with public
participation not a public meeting
therefore only persons who have
registered to speak will be allowed to
do so this evening we are being webcast
so if you don't wish to be shown then
please make that you've known to an
officer at the appropriate time for our
speaker some tips on using the
microphone don't get too close to it
otherwise it gets distorted and you just
keep backing away and forward so just
put it a few inches away
scoop see clearly and it will be all
right I'm sure right the sequence of
events is as follows I will introduce
the item supported by the case officer
there will offer a description town and
parish from counselors be allowed to
speak for up to three minutes members of
public rejecting will be allowed to
speak for up to three minutes or six on
the first item the applicant will them
beyond speak for a committed time in
this particular first item would be nine
minutes I will give a a warning probably
30 seconds before your time is up
what members um will then be allowed to
speak for up to five minutes at all
stages the members the committee relay
you're able to question our speakers
following the presentation then we will
move to technical questions for the case
officer and then on to debate and the
vote all this is detailed in the agenda
could I please ask your to turn your
mobile phones either off or to silent
for the duration of the meeting please
write there is an update sheet and I'm
going to pause and let the members of
the committee have a read of this this
is late-breaking news or items that need
to be updated before we go into
the actual meeting right so I'm just
going to take a pause for a moment and
then we'll go into introductions members
if you could have a look at the update
sheet and let me know when you weren't
ready please
thank you very much than that and I'll
move on now I'd like to ask the officers
to introduce themselves starting from my
right place Caroline Nash committee
administrator Ross chambers legal
services Joe Archie Warwickshire County
Council highways I wanna bus
planning officer David million ship
planning officer thank you right
now let's set up move into the agenda
this evening our first is apologies for
absence
apologies receive from councillor
Charles William accounts for fielding is
substituting Thank You
disclosures of interest members
obviously if there are any items on the
agenda this evening that you have a an
interest in councillor Karrueche
yep the first item relatives in gateway
are not principally against it I have
been sitting in discussions with the
applicant and the various councils to
get the most acceptable application
possible really but on advice although I
haven't objected or supported the
proposal I have decided to not sit on
the committee but comment as a ward
member and also on application for the
Victoria works number six I've well I've
objected so I'll be commenting as a
member okay and thank you for entering
into discussions debate with the
developers which lot beforehand I think
that's important for all the members to
do that counts a pain Thank You chairman
application number 17 0 to double 6 1
ful a team or pit road I should be
speaking as Ward member thank you chair
yeah I did see on the agenda Oh two five
nine two four Billy I'm the warden
member and I'll be speaking on that so
it would not be taken upon the debate
thank you very much members have you
seen the minutes of the meeting and are
you happy for those two sets of me I
mean
are you happy for me to sign them after
the meeting okay thank you very much
right our first item on the agenda this
evening is 1701 847 slash out which is
called reddit gateway now I know the
real number of speakers this evening
and I also know that people have made
comments about the timings and suchlike
but I'd like to say first of all is I've
allowed an extra three minutes for
objectors on this one so the the rule is
three minutes for the Parrish six
minutes for objectors now what we're
going to do is split that one and a half
minutes per person because we haven't
been advised of any other arrangement
between yourselves on that one and then
we have the applicants have a committed
time which is going to be nine minutes
and then the ward meant we'll have five
minutes
I appreciate that also that counsel
right is the joining ward members unable
to be here this evening her husband's
not pretty well so I think councilor
carriage is aware of that and if there's
any comments that he can incorporate
into his five minutes I'm sure he will
do so if that is possible okay I've only
one happy on that one well I would also
say to you speakers please is this you
only have one and a half minutes
appreciate that's very difficult to try
and get all your information across
however if I could ask you please to
raise all of your concerns within your
time scale and then I am sure that the
all of the members will be asking able
to ask questions of you and then perhaps
we can tease out any particular issues
or concerns that you have in that time
okay thank you
right so 17-0 one eight four seven
switch out Alice Thank You chairman as
members will be aware and then the site
visit took place this afternoon counts
as car girl carriage pain and fielding
were in attendance the application site
which denoted by the black dot in the
center of the plan is located on the
edge of the built-up area of redditch
the site is allocated for employment
development in the core strategy the
development to the south of the Coventry
highway the main
Road which dissect the site is allocated
under policy red to whilst the
development to the north of the Coventry
highway is allocated under policy red
one the application site falls within
the jurisdictions of stratford-on-avon
District Council redditch Borough
Council and Bromsgrove District Council
the plan on screen shows the areas of
site which fall into each local
authority area three identical
applications have been submitted to each
authority this aerial photograph shows
the application site in the context of
its surroundings the roofs of the
industrial units on the Raven Bank
Business Park can be seen to the
northwest of the site with the existing
residential development of farm or lane
to the southwest boundary the yellow
stars indicate nearby listed buildings
Gore cut halt to its northeast is grade
2 star listed with with those to the
south of the site being grade 2 listed
this hybrid planning application seeks
outlined consent with matters of
appearance landscaping layout scale and
details of internal circulation routes
reserved for the development on a phased
basis of 32 hectares of employment land
for business and industrial uses and
full planning permission for the phase 1
ground engineering works and primary
means of access to the site from the
Coventry Highway the parameters plan
submitted
shows various employment zones detailing
maximum building heights the pink areas
would have a maximum height of 21 meters
with the yellow a maximum height of 15
meters and brown maximum Heights of 9
meters the gray section would be for
parking only whilst the green areas to
note undeveloped areas as advised the
full element of the scheme includes the
means of access from the Coventry
Highway this photograph shows the
existing road layout the Northern Pass
saw of the site is on the left-hand side
of the photo with the southern parcel on
the right-hand side and this plan shows
the proposed access layouts which forms
part of the full element the access
would comprise a new signal controlled
crossroads Junction the full also
includes the ground works associated
with creating the first development
platform which would have banking
to its parameter there would be no
requirements for soil to be brought on
all off the site this slide shows an
illustrative master plan the final
design if outline elements would be
subject to reserve Mathers approval but
this provides an indication of how
development may come forward
this photo is taken from far more lane
to the southwest boundary of the site
existing perimeter planting can be seen
and this would be bolstered as part of
the dualities of development the
dwellings on Halle Berry clothes can be
seen and I've just got a couple of
videos to show you so if you can just
take note of this you can see where I'm
standing in the location of video 1 and
where I'm standing in the location of
video 2 so video 1 taken from the
Southern through the southern part of
the site just panning round so I've got
the public footpath and far more laying
behind me you can just see the a 4 3 5
in the distance it goes quite dark here
that should lighten up and then this is
the existing perimeter Lant landscaping
which would be bolstered and as we pan
further round to the left you can see
the public footpath and then the
dwellings long hope clothes which lies
to the southwest of the site and video
to just of the northern parcel so this
is just panning around just to give
members an idea of the topography so
it's all fairly flat here it does rise
up the woodland at the end is outside
the application site and then Ravens
Bank Business Park can be seen there
members should note that there are a
number of updates to the application as
detailed within the update sheet this
includes an amendment to the
recommendation relating to the 200
thousand pound bond the recommended
amendment would be that the bond is paid
on first occupation and held for a
period of 15 years from its receipt or
until 12 months after the last premises
is occupied whichever is the sooner
chairman the recommendation is to
approve the application subject to the
legal agreement to secure the 200
thousand pound bond
described as well as biodiversity
offsetting and conditions are detailed
within the committee report thank you
thank you very much as our first speaker
this evening is Steven Coley
from a macabre green parish council
Steven thank you you have three minutes
in your own time yes by all means
sorry yeah that's fine and when you're
ready just press a button at the bottom
and then the red light comes on you can
speak and I'll give you a short but not
immediately no said okay and first of
all I'd say that we've had as a mapable
growing punish camp we've had no
correspondence or talks or dialogue with
anybody concerned it's not for the
people that are doing it any of the
council's they're not spoken to us at
all which i think is very rude of
everybody having said that we have three
large nurseries from Alberta Green
Island
we had three large nurseries one of them
actually on the island all the car parks
for 100 cars and all got restaurants
behind the pub on the island is a school
with no car parking bits all next to
that we've got a 24-hour garage which
which is got a quite pink back to it and
then we have a Chinese restaurant which
is just computation for six units to go
behind and then we have another one the
amount of the vehicles that come up and
down the road are thousands well we've
now got to look forward to we've got the
240 houses which you're going next to
this site which are part of the core
strategy we've got a hotel in just at
the back of us Warner's hotel and the
people go from Monty - Monty till Friday
and Friday till Monday that's got 240
bedrooms any trophies coming down a
floor three fathers got to come round
that Island we're told that there's
going to be approximately between 1700
and 2400 people working on this site
whether they're going to drive there and
drive out they've got to come two ways
or one of those round the island it's
just too much for us we can't have any
more we're talking about a next 2,000
cars there
a nexus 6 or 700 cars at the hotel I'm a
Monday of Friday it's just chock-a-block
intelligence of the factory as such if
they were promised me I wouldn't be
complaining this all by they but it's
not you son I don't step we can't even
get out the lines now at the end of prep
slide because you're bound up from study
now because we've got a sorry study
you've got a restaurant analogies you've
got to turn left into that gets full
people can turn right she's a chucker
it's just too much it's just too much
traffic
we can't take anymore it's a I think
that they ought to be putting a
bypassing or a road that goes round
mother would agree Sarah you know this
shouldn't have blamed you I will not
blaming anybody all these things have
happened when when they started planning
the factory they didn't know about the
hotel they've been to them nurseries
they've got the bigger and bigger
yeah the wrong million pound nurseries
that with all being rich they're all the
carpark for me it's just too much
traffic how much should we gotta take
we're taking the blunt of everything 30
seconds please right where's the site it
should be nice to think that they you
could incorporate in the planning so
sort of that have got to find a way
round up a bit agree they've got to it's
just we just can't take anymore thank
you thank you very much
before you go if you wouldn't mind
staying for a moment just in case any of
our members like your chat please sit
down it's okay members are any questions
you'd like to ask
certainly counsel fielding where you
refer to an island where what is the
island site that you're referring to
this one nobody goes from up above if
there's only one island in one of 435
he's further down the hill from there so
it's the one at the bottom there that
she's got a marked out there yeah well
that'll be the island yes
so the island is is the the road game
off to the right and then this area row
coming down further up to create a
triangle of area there or is that just
my map all the traffic that gets their
arms come through struggling and they'd
some laughable agreement I mean it's the
what approaches the road that goes
across on the corner of that island
there's a pub on one corner and inertia
on the other corner they're building ten
houses on the opposite for you just to
clarify you're saying that during the
period of time to two addresses you
haven't had any work or consultation
with the developers on this none at all
not us okay thank you
alright any other questions members
thank you very much indeed thank you
right our next speakers our accounts are
Beeman Christopher Eden and Maureen
berry and Lesley Clark
[Applause]
are not believed and the clarity
caroline is going to read mr. Eden's a
statement obviously there are if there
are any questions that you need to be
asked they can be done so afterwards not
sure how you want to handle this if I
could just clarify
Kinski Eden is here with me as chair
help answer questions if there's any
arise from ever that's what I'm going to
do is at the end of your time I'll stop
and we can ask questions individually
before we carry on to the next speakers
thank you thank you very much yeah we'll
give you a 30-second warning as well so
minute and a half minute a half okay I
will do my best over to you thank you
thank you Jay when I was a counselor I
was assured permission would not be
granted for this development and less
traffic issues have been addressed we
are extremely concerned that HTTP
routing strategies even if followed and
enforced will have zero impact on the
workforce traffic HDV routing plans who
will be almost impossible to enforce
especially when there are issues on
surrounding road networks the additional
workforce traffic isn't being given
sufficient weight with the emphasis of
white only be given to HCV route
mitigation and with unemployment low in
the region we believe this will
therefore greatly increase the traffic
volumes of commuters for a village with
a aqra already in place incidentally
even one additional HTV or vehicle of
any kind is worsening and already
publicly accepted for unacceptable
dangerous situation and this subsequent
disregard to the health and safety of
air residents would constitute nothing
short of negligence the requires of the
MPP effort set out a clear requirement
that development in one location must
not have a negative impact on another it
was the limited data available at
present will say consider a worsening of
the problem members of the committee
you're all aware as well if you are
there there is currently a task force
passport
both local MPs county and district
council members and officers attempting
to find a way to admitted that the
problems along the a 435
it's there considered and strongly held
belief that approving this development
in its current guys his country and he
baterry inhibitory to that development
please not now
we urge you to listen to the weight of
resident opinions as it is us who will
be affected by this decision both in the
short term and for many years to come
thank you Thank You councillor then is
there any questions you'd like to ask
obviously I just want to pick up on the
transport plan now some of these
questions you've raised especially those
are quite technical and we do happen to
have our highways expert yes I'm afraid
you're an expert now this evening so we
will write will raise those particular
queries with with with them at the
appropriate time we've actually got them
from both Bromsgrove and from Stratford
so we can ask any questions on that one
so can I just clarify a count so it's
really the traffic which is the main
concern to yourselves and yes there are
other concerns have been listed in the
agenda they are in there but I think we
wanted to emphasize the problems with
the traffic and what we perceive will be
the biggest problem from this
development should it be given
permission okay I think obviously I was
also at the summit just to declare an
interest on that particular $4 at the
summit isn't a Jamie joining County
Board member and when it happened a few
weeks ago right thank you for that any
of the questions members okay I think
that's it thank you very much thank you
our next speaker then and I have down as
Kristin do you want to do that one okay
Caroline's going to read out the
statement there obviously
total sites north and south vehicle
parking and lorry usage 1590 car parking
bays and 87 articulated lorry bays
operating 24/7 well articulated lorries
have 12 litre diesel engines car diesel
engines about 1.6 litres diesel fee
contain over ten times the amount of
soot particles these include several
calso calcio genic substances causing
cancer of the lungs and bladder also
COPD and emphysema traffic this will
affect people's health and well-being
government is trying to reduce traffic
congestion and get diesel vehicles off
the road there are so many vacant
offices and warehouses your plan
employment for 2500 people in low tech
minimum-wage jobs what happened to the
plan to a diversification part for high
tech low-rise offices which would
produce high paid jobs size warehouse
southern flight a a front print 5.8
acres or three football pitches volume
five hundred and eight thousand two
hundred meters cubes height two x three
bed houses on top of each other
BB front print 3.6 acres or two football
pitches volume three hundred two
thousand four hundred meters cubes
height two x three bed houses on top of
each other
opposite established housing a state of
windy eight screen warehouse a a only
100 meters from center farm or lane and
warehouse BB 55 meters thank you I'm
just gonna summarize a little bit on
that one who don't mind and see if you
agree with me I think obviously your
concerns are parking noise traffic
pollution especially obviously with the
ATVs and the like
if you look at the warehouses all the
space around those warehouses are taken
up by car parking areas for the
employees so if you can go to that
picture the southern picture there you
can see if you bring that up if you blow
it up begin and then rise it now you can
lift that look Camden yeah just bring it
down and Peter right there's a
residential area on the well I'm sitting
the left hand side yes and the corner of
our first warehouse is only 55 meters
from far more line but so close it is to
the residential area and there is no way
you can screen it when it's 2 3 3 2 he's
21 meters high which is roughly over
actually two three-bedroom houses on top
of each other and the other the bigger
one of the way a houses with your brief
you can just bring it down the beach I'm
as far down as it will go drop to go up
nice I know right at the bottom of the
round sorry my apologies
that one there is a hundred meters away
from the center of the road and there's
no way that can be screamed from the
residential properties there's no way
the saying can be emitted although they
put death at put ran an acoustic fencing
that doesn't stop the lorries in the
evening from bleeping when they're
reversing okay I get that one and yes I
think yes and noise is an issue as well
okay thank you
councillor fielding could you want ask
question do you do did these various
parishes did you go to the wreckage
Riddick
when they gave their approval for this
were you involved in that decision or
presentation on their core strategy
presentation yes we presented at all of
the meetings for the core strategy I
still gave approval yes I think you
remembers any other questions no thank
you very much right next speaker is
Maureen Barry Maureen you have one and a
half minutes in your own time and I'm
the governor of the macabre game green
village school which the Church of
England school we've got an ongoing
problem relating to the saturation of
traffic on the a 435 in the a four one
eight nine which is so far course three
scene serious accidents and several
minor accidents we are working to try
and alleviate this problem at this
moment in time with ground Stanley of
work sure highways and the police are
well aware and have not been notified
and they are trying to help under the
safe journeys to school policy I would
therefore ask you not to assassinate the
problem by granting permission for this
development which per a letter that I
have already submitted to you that was
written by the rel each MP appears that
read each don't want the development
Napa borough certainly doesn't want the
development
we the only people that I can actually
see that can benefit from this
development are the developers and the
council themselves under the s106 rules
which unfortunately seems to only be
from an economic benefit we're a Church
of England school but the road is too
dangerous to walk the children
approximately 400 metres to the church
this obviously will only get worse if
the development is granted surely in 30
seconds please surely an industrial site
working 24/7 with the capacity to park
87 hdvs let alone the vehicles that are
currently the possible 2,600 jobs can
only increase the problem of both
traffic and air pollution currently the
site is a green field however air
pollution is still high so too will
increase to saturation with the
saturation of traffic flow it will only
serve to increase significant the lungs
of the young children subjective ask you
to wrap up now please well alright I say
please do not that metal borough green
be the second school to be knocking on
10 downing street stores pleading for
the right to breathe clean air to sum up
is a child's life worth more to me he's
worth more than mere money I think not
okay thank you and I will only take that
from you
many for me humanities point of view
that you'll agree with me thank you
members there are any questions you'd
like to ask I'm sorry how many children
are there we've got 124 children at the
school at age even for to be leading
okay thank you although any other
questions mr. fielding do the children
come from the they come across many come
across from Worcester and we've got
problems with them cross crossing the
roads
yes they do come that's that that's the
problem we're working on at the moment
we've just had temporary traffic lights
put in for a time because we had no car
parking at all because the pub quite
generously lets us use their car park
but they they stopped us using it for a
turn because they were doing
refurbishments and we had to have
temporary traffic lights put in to just
to get the children to school
all right thank you very much indeed our
final speaker this evening is mr. Clark
there's the cop it's like you have one
half minutes in your own time
can I just introduce myself first my own
place Clark I been a resident of
Wingate's green for the last thirty
years you'll excuse me if I just breathe
because my wife says it's one minute 35
seconds so good evening it's unlikely
we'll quibble over five seconds I'm on
my way
Monday night in Bromsgrove they met for
to meet the theists application but I
can only report one thing that they were
concerned about is how they got their
hands on their two hundred thousand
pound bond so I asked myself on the way
home how could I convince you in one
minute to refuse this application could
I say it's not needed there are
thousands of square feet of empty
warehouses in village could I say the
traffic on the April 35 is a bomb as
we've heard this plan will make it worse
well about the sixty eight foot high
buildings the parking problem the noise
the drainage all important that they
pale into insignificance by one thing
and I hope you will not overlook it air
pollution I have a question for you is
there nothing on councils to provide a
safe and healthy environment for its
residents almost every week the reports
published pointing out the risk of
health of diesel pollution from diesel
pollution it must be so because d'etre
is spending billions attempting to
reduce it has a quality monitoring been
done at this site never no only computer
modeling but what about the two thousand
jobs somebody might say well how does
that work there are they only going to
employ people from ready of course not
it's just a figure plucked out of their
polluted air the reference to this site
as employment land I ask you to wrap up
short who decided and why is that look
at the screen this beautiful green
Warwickshire countryside somewhere
month's aptly wrote a rose by any other
name
would smell as sweet stop for labor why
are you destroying your own heritage
thank you thank you and apologies to
women your Shakespeare thank you very
much indeed mr. Clark and they've got
the questions that you've raised or
point you rate in there certainly about
drainage air pollution I will raise
those with it in the technical questions
section as well so I think we got the
gist of of what your your eyeglass
members are any questions you'd like to
ask I can't think of any more I need to
ask at the moment I pick up the point
incidentally about air quality
monitoring and I'll raise up one of the
technical question but thank you very
much speakers that's very kind of you
thank you right our next speakers are
Robb wells the agent we have then
between them Alex Morgan Tim Cook
massive oil to ask answer any questions
that members may have you have 9 minutes
on your own time thank you Thank You
charlie hopefully I wanted to turn you
for that length of time and before I
start I was going to dutifully done that
so just but I would like to make respond
to the point raised by a green patch
council saying that had no indication of
no consultation with us then we have
actually they were invited on to the
public consultation events and some of
them actually came along above carry on
from thank you that the plane in front
of you is highly important this the
first step into living Redditch gateway
one of four priority game-changing
employment sites for woofster share and
read each in particular the application
area parent is a hybrid
seeking outlined planning permission for
the overall development and for planning
permission to enable the early delivery
the new access into the site
on the first phase of groundworks the
development will provide a significant
boost of the local economy and an
estimated 2,000 new jobs when completed
the repose was represented develop value
of 100 million pounds for the local area
the development is supported by water
local enterprise partnership north water
to share economic development to
regeneration and greater Birmingham and
Sol your local enterprise partnership it
is also one of the projects identified
in the department for international
trade invest in Great Britain and
Northern Ireland portfolio focusing on
the Midlands engine area you've heard
from your officers at the site lies
within three districts Bromsgrove
considered the proposal on Monday
evening and resolved to grant permission
redish council will be considering the
application next week you have
effectively been asked by the speakers
why there's a need of the development
and why here as a planning committee you
know the need for councils to have local
plans in place to plan for the
development needs of their area and to
provide a portfolio of sites the need to
boost the supply of jobs is one of the
key themes of the national planning
Quality Framework the site as a whole is
allocated for permit development in your
adopted core strategy and Bromsgrove
local plan the allocations were a result
of the joint working between the three
councils under the duty to cooperate to
meet the identified employment needs of
Revit this followed a thorough review of
existing employment land including
vacant land by redditch Council and a
site selection process which considered
all possible alternative areas the
approach was fully endorsed by the
inspectors are the local plan
examinations who each thoroughly
interrogated both the need for
development and the choice of side the
need for employment development was
recognised as being so important that it
constituted very special circumstances
to release the land from the Greenbelt
to reiterate no part of the site is
within Greenbelt
the application submissions has followed
among two years extensive
pre-application discussion with the
three councils to hirez authorities
how is England and static lands forties
that recommend is mindful of the need to
ensure that the development works
successfully and has recognised that
there are local concerns about
development in principle traffic and
highways biodiversity
technical issues including flooding this
was clearly explained to us by the local
community at our consultation events the
applicants listened carefully to those
concerns and only submit to the
application when they consider that the
issues raised had been resolved we
consider it's a testament to the joint
working that the statue Council tees
subject to the conditions in the section
106 being recommended are satisfied with
the proposals the outline element of the
application identifies a series of
parameters including areas for building
areas to be kept free from development
landscaping and drainage the parameters
also set out the maximum Heights of
building which vary across the site
together these parameters will control
how the development comes forward
through future applications for reserved
matters approval and the restricted
master plan has been provided to show
how a future development might look but
as an illustrative plan it is not the
final development and does not form one
of the plans that we hope you approve
this evening the applications provide
for a new access into the site as a
signalized Junction on the country
highway the delivery of the junction
forms part of the full application
extensive modeling and highways analysis
of the development as a whole to assess
the effective development on the network
including traffic distribution has been
carried out and the results accepted by
the Highways England Warwickshire and
Worcestershire highways authorities the
applicant has agreed to mitigation
measures where they are needed as a
direct consequence for the development
the applicant is also demonstrated the
parking can be provided in accordance
with local guidelines and is also making
provision to improve access for their
students of cyclists and probably
transport we're working closely with
high road authorities the applicant has
also agreed to implement restrictions on
HTV routing to minimize impacts on the
local higher network and areas of lesser
air quality subject to the recommended
section 106 and post conditions the
proposals are considered to be fully
satisfactory in high-risk terms and the
high res authorities and highways
England have confirmed this through
their responses similarly no objections
have been raised from your console T's
regarding impacts on air quality
extensive discussion has also inherited
the Heritage cost sorties including your
conservation officer to ensure that the
proposals appropriately mitigate impacts
on
assets notably cannot cut all the
parameters of the proposed development
balance the need to make efficient use
of the land and protect the setting of
the hall the develop our parameters
proposed ensure that a suitable distance
is maintained between new buildings and
the hall and the height of new buildings
is controlled the parameters for the
development have been developed on a
holistic basis to return the existing
trees and hedges where possible and
where change has to take place to
include proposals for appropriate
compensation and mitigation key features
such as the black soils brought are
retained and incorporated into proposal
and escaping inevitably there will be
some impacts there isn't as there is
need to be grade land to form
development platforms amendments have
been made to rehearsals following the
consultation responses under negotiation
with your offices to exclude
southernmost part of the southern site
from being development and we believe
this demonstrates the applicants
willingness to cooperate effectively
with councils a comprehensive
sustainable drainage proposal has also
been submitted to ensure that there is
no increased risk of flooding from the
site the proposals actually improve
drainage and reduce the risk of flooding
through the introduction of new drainage
ponds and controlled release of waters
into the local network and the
management of existing water courses
this is been one of the key priorities
for the applicant not only to ensure
that surface water is carefully managed
but also to ensure there are no adverse
effects on the up to the olders large
triple si in Redditch pura in conclusion
the application influenced view has been
carefully designed through proactive and
constructive dialogue between the
applicant the councils and the consul
T's is sure that it can deliver
development worthy of the game-changer
status of the site the report to you is
clear that subject the proposed section
106 and conditions the proposals are
acceptable and the Planning Commission
should be granted we trust that you will
agree with your officers recommendation
thank you very much thank you obviously
there's a few questions I'm sure already
first of all you were challenged by one
of the speakers at least one if I'm not
mistaken about the need for this site ie
the fact that there are vacant premises
and full employment etc so could you
just explain the reasoning behind
bringing this
and the viability argument please as I
mentioned in my my speech to you local
council required to plan proactively for
their development needs across the plan
period for at least a future 15 year
period in doing so they then have to
bring forward development land to meet
that requirement Redditch undertook that
process and identified a need for
additional land than they had in within
their borough and that takes account of
the existing employment portfolio
existing vacant buildings existing
vacant land that isn't already allocated
as employment having taken all that into
account
there was still a deficit in the amount
of land that they had in to meet the
projected development requirements this
site was identified following us a very
detailed site selection process whereby
they looked at all that I'm the round
red edge it was identified through the
sustainability appraised on a fine
selection process as being the most
appropriate site to meet the additional
requirement for Redick thank you
first of all members Richard thank you
gentlemen thanks for that most concerns
me is the access and traffic arrangement
scuse me can you talk me through how you
got to the access Arrangements that
you've presented there how we've gone
from or got two signals basically in my
view it would be much more sensible to
have free-flowing and roundabouts there
just talk us through how that you pass
road of course you can't we actually did
start looking at a roundabout to
initially to start with because you've
got the moves by roundabout to the west
and system of merchandisers to the east
the actual roundabouts couldn't be
designed with horns with the right
design standards which is why we end up
in a signal juncture provide the same
amount of capacity but actually can be
designed correctly can you elaborate on
those design standards it's it's
difficult it's a lot to do with the
actual distance between between
junctions the actual weaving distance
which is
distance between people moving from one
Junction to another being out has
changed lanes with a sufficient spacing
the quarantine quarantine national
guidance we couldn't provide that with a
roundabout but we can with a single
control jump Thank You Council bonds I'm
sure you've heard that everybody's
concern about the road I'm sure you as
well point is is that are you putting
any crops in did my cut by the school or
any other place or if you were asked to
would you or with that in the plan thank
council er and as I've mentioned the
develop proposals have been subject to
two years minimum of application
discussion which is thoroughly tested
for highways and access proposals we've
got a position whereby that the howie's
authorities are satisfied with what is
work forward there are no proposals for
any crossings of the a43 five that's
part and parcel in terms of pedestrian
crossings as apart part of the
application but the new junction that
we've been posing on the a four to three
will include provisions for pedestrian
crossings to link the north and south
sides council fielding i'll the the bill
are you looking to spec build or are you
going to be doing turnkey operations for
plants I'll start to decline my jump in
it won't be spec which have built in the
first instance it will be to respond to
specific occupier Thank You chair Alice
if you wouldn't mind could you bring
back the the previous slide that's the
fella yeah thanks I mean this
development and granted is an outline
application one thing that has been
raised by residents opposite is this the
height of the buildings and it strikes
me that the tallest these are b8
distribution warehouses 21 meters high
that they're not massive employment
generators but they are big buildings
why he stucked on the south side of the
site so it's very close to the
residential realm on the north side of
the site where it has minimal impacts
and certainly looking at Lee at the
north west side that would be adjoining
what are very big buildings anyway it
just seems that you might have got in
your layout the wrong way around
you could comment on that please Thank
You counselor this simple answer is the
Aryan Bromsgrove is like to be degraded
to enable the levels the southern most
area to the south a 43 is the flattest
part of the side so it is most
appropriate or suitable for that type of
building the area to the immediate north
of the area 43 in terms of the grading
you can see it's quite it's a narrower
angled development that we have issues
of setting of the Gortat Hall so we
weren't in a position to be able to put
large builders on that part of the
development side in terms of the 21
meters height if I might just may answer
that point please not the tallest at a
building of this nature could be they go
up to 25 to 28 meters in certain
instances but it's part and parcel
occasion we submitted the full landscape
and visual impact assessment to show how
how the buildings would potentially sit
within the landscape in the surrounding
area yeah I just pick up with castle law
on the particular point I think we've
during our site visit we did identify
concerns about the area down far more
Lane so perhaps we can raise that on a
little bit later on right just do one
other one I wanted to pay for we're
talking about build big buildings and
such like and correct me wrong is this
just going to be literally distribution
and the like or as was mentioned during
the the the the speakers about east it
was originally some high-tech employment
on there so you can just elaborate on
that please
canceled applications for mix of b1 b2
and b8 hi-tech
falls within the b1 category so there is
potential for high tech to come forward
as part part of the development of
puzzles you'll see that we have our most
likely to be shown on the develop
rameters they like to come into the
yellow and the orange areas they were
shown in the northern because of the
nature the types of buildings and the
size of buildings that they would likely
to be seeking so there is potential for
that that's how they used to come
forward or through the application comes
fielding ready to are concerned about
flooding problems going on-site the
Brooke there how do you propose to
present there are you going to Dre are
you going to pipe it or you're going to
leave it as an open drain or how are you
going to handle that one well I can I'll
start at home by calling my joining part
and parcel of the filling at the moment
it is because of the management of the
existing water course is that hasn't
been upheld for quite some time so
there's a lot of drain it backs the
Brahms Brook drains under the a 402 3
and then into a culvert near farm or
Lane and that backs up quite often which
creates a lot of the flooding problems
that this experience to present so the
proposals will include management of the
existing what courses you will see when
the drawings there that there are areas
shown blue which will provide for new
attenuation ponds and treatment of water
once the waters gone through that it's
and they're controlled release into the
existing water courses so actually the
rate of runoff will be no more than the
green field runoff that is currently can
I just pick up on traffic items that
were mentioned as well obviously there's
going to be generation of traffic if
they are going to be distribution
warehouses etc concerns have been raised
and you're probably fully aware with the
traffic going through
Macabre now obviously and Studley
because they they on the same road how
are you going to mitigate those there's
a impacts on the local community again
if I can transfer that 50-mile transport
colleague
there's two parts to it probably the HTV
routing plan which I think we touched on
earlier will take will each other the
HTV sorry the PCB routing plan that he's
proposing will be conditioned probably
application walk will take HD visa after
between sure they don't go through
studly or macabre but that will be
secured through the condition and
there's a the bond will be in place to
subsidize any measures that if anything
doesn't work and I'll be monitored by
work she and Worcestershire sorry if I
may just add on to that as I mentioned
in my talk it has been subject to
extensive modeling from to share and
actually Howard authorities and I was
England yeah I'm sure
look we're talking to our officers on
high pressure right I posted here what
you were going to do and if there
anything that there's parts of the
parcel of that extensive modeling then
we have agreed to well the the
provisions in the application are agreed
with the highest authorities as being
suitable provision for cars and traffic
so the server in terms of the
application and our understanding from
from from the staff T console T's there
are no additional requirements necessary
just going to follow on from I noticed
it in the north part there were Springs
that are coming out probably from the
bank on the higher ground
can you cap those are you what are you
doing planning on doing about those to
stop flooding there we're aware the
ground is quite wet and there are a
number of outlets of Springs we would be
looking to try and pick those up with
land rains and bring them into the Black
Horse Brook depending where they live we
would take them into the drainage system
there is part of the the drainage
strategy is to have a lot of open
ditches rather than piping both from a
water cleansing
native and more sustainable I'm just
picking up on that particular point
buffering of them during obviously for
your you know tarmac and concrete the
roads exactly is there a buffering a
solution for this to stop the the flows
going straight into the well the whole
system really yes so the the water be
captured off this hard surfaces and
going to the ditch courses and the ditch
courses with gain going to whilst we've
shown them as blue these are capturing
ponds they will not necessarily have
that amount of water footprint all the
time they were there to capture the
water and then the outflow will be
throttled to take the water eventually
back into the local network disposals
coming from lorries etc that may get
into those water courses are you going
to trap them or or what what have you
got in mind for those obviously the
detailed rainy skin will be subject to
agreement with the councils and the
relevant drainage authorities but they
will the design of those will have to
include some form of interceptors to
assure the oil or the pollutants don't
get into the water courses are there any
other questions members no thank you
very much indeed thank you alright
councillor carriage
amber to you five minutes
okay you're lucky I've written it down
today
mm-hmm okay so we know this is a
headline application and the only
detailed application is on access but
there are parameters which we are
looking at about the heights and aspects
around environmental aspects traffic
generation and the business class use we
are considering those and we're deciding
on those tonight in our policy this site
is described as a high quality business
park but within the constraints of
listed buildings traffic impact visual
impact and ecology what we have before
us tonight does not sufficiently address
those constraints if I can quote our
policy existing traffic flows already
cause environmental impacts and there's
a designated air quality management area
in the middle of struggling effective
ways of mitigating the impact of this
traffic will need to be identified and
implemented as an integral part of the
development proposals also nature
conservation the nature conservation
value of some parts of the area and the
effect on the setting of Gorka Hall
which is great to listed buildings we've
got those two issues are very plainly
raised in our policy so on to traffic
after those important words hgv routing
plan
it's an idea it's a great idea I think
it's an essential part of anything that
happens on this site but there's nothing
before us tonight there's no evidence
that this will be effective there's
nothing to look at
there's no proof
can work and no suggestions of how if it
doesn't work the traffic will be
mitigated
it's nothing here to look at the two
hundred thousand pounds has been
suggested to mitigate anything if it
doesn't work it's a incredibly small
amount of money to make any significant
road changes so there's no plan as far
as I can see of what those changes might
be okay so we've got no plans to address
that we can't we can't approve it
without that it's in our policy that we
must take seriously
that's just HGVs
there's absolutely nothing nothing on
the increased car movements we've heard
it might not be relevant the number of
car journeys going through steadily but
the highways report in the in this
report from Worcestershire and Warrick
she's on page 32 they say there will be
a a one minute increase in queuing time
heading south on the a 435 from this
site now I don't know what that means
but it's something one minute increase
on queuing from from nothing is is is is
considerable and and they say this is
extra traffic which will be queuing will
disperse before it hits totally but this
is time traffic queuing increases okay
it flies in the face of logic that that
this can dissipate we have a queues a
few hundred yards down the road in map
of the green from the junction they're
talking about so it can't dissipate it
will join that queue and then further
down the road you've got studly massive
queues into slowly Oh big times ok so
there's nowhere for this extra traffic
which is identified to dissipate too so
it will add to a situation which is
already damaging to people's health and
this is not hyperbole because it it
already exceeded levels proven to be
dangerous to people's health so if it
can't be ameliorated it should not be
allowed
this is our policy but there's no plan
here to deal with it
so that's traffic visual impact on
heritage buildings on residential areas
and on public views from the a 435
heritage and conservation experts at
Bromsgrove
disappointment at the 21 meters height
as opposed to the 18 meters which they
say was the original suggestions so this
raises the harm to more than the
midpoint in less than considerable harm
okay it's not just to the Heritage it's
to the people who live in the nearby
buildings and it's to the view from the
a 435 great there's what else but thanks
before we carry on with any other
questions you mentioned some conditions
against our policy could you just
elaborate on which those conditions work
please I have mentioned conditions yeah
about design really that if this is if
this is passed tonight I hope it's not
because I don't think we're we're ready
to pass it we haven't got the
information I did send in a letter that
this is supposed to be a high quality
Business Park
we're supposed to be attracting higher
quality jobs to Redditch and it's not
suitable as a purely distribution and
sorted storage facility so the visual
impact of that kind of development isn't
appropriate so we we must when it comes
to reserved matters if it ever gets to
reserved matters we must be looking at
design and we must be able to justify
these large buildings in the update
sheet about notes to be added to ensure
good quality design materials cause
Keeneland
escaping etc or Reserve's matter stage
and also the tree cover I'm just going
to go through the audio things appears
hard as a construction condition 17 HTTP
2 routing which we will ask our experts
on this now and biodiversity again we
can ask those things so yes we've got it
covered in your update sheet I've got it
covered in it the updated one thing that
wasn't mentioned in the update she was
an hgv routing plan for the construction
phase also pick up with the officers the
two hundred thousand pound bond which
are you've raised and I'll pick up on a
persona that came with you ok any
questions members ok it's this area only
sorry if this area part in reddit or is
it part in were Stratford in if the
officers part in Redditch well there's a
hedgerow in Redditch does the north
western part in Bromsgrove and the rest
of its in in Stratford the implication
north this was in the core strategy
other buildings that the height they are
and the use of what we had agreed in the
core strategy I think that's my point
it's in principle you know the fact that
we're going to have is in our policies
you know in principle I'm not against
doing we've got address the traffic
that's one thing but when it comes to
the height in the northern parcel
there's been an attempt to to structure
the development from low to high to
avoid harm to the go cut halt listed
building I think 21 meters at the far
northwestern point is still too high and
and I think comments from the
conservation officer
no this is this is outline but these are
the parameters we are setting now so
we're setting that parameter of up to 21
meters for the whole southern side
without any any idea of how it's going
to affect the views from the a4 through
5 the people who live next door to it
just picking up cancer about the fact
that you don't agree what we're saying
about the outline permissions but as was
stated it was B 1 B 2 B 8 I think so
there are a range of available for site
what eventually turns up on there I
think is is for the future we can
specify that at this time however I do
pick up your point about that and I will
actually we'll discuss that as well
thank you very much any other questions
members no thank you thank you right
members are there any technical
questions right I think I've been asked
to we have been getting for now now I'm
gonna take a five-minute comfort break
okay everybody so five minutes three
minutes confirmation thank you
item eight on the agenda this evening
has actually been withdrawn from from
tonight's proceedings just put everyone
there right next item then is questions
for the officers obviously we have our
highways officers and also Alice what do
counsel Richard thank you this will be
for our highways experts initially so
this I'm trying to understand this
access obviously you've heard my
question was about whether we should
have had a roundabout or not can you
explain to me what it is about the
distances between roundabouts that
couldn't be achieved and and if there
were other thoughts as to a different
style of access than that okay if they
started looking at around about there
are certain design standards that are
set out in the design manual for roads
and bridges that would have to be
adhered to and if they couldn't then
they're identified as being departures
and they then happen to be if they can't
be overcome by tweaks to the design they
have to go through an exception report
process which means Head of Service has
to be able to confidently sign off those
otherwise they can't be built and
obviously when they were looking at the
roundabout preliminary design they felt
that there were too many departures for
them to go down that route which was why
the roundabout was taken away and they
came up with the traffic signal option
instead so it's that the standards are
acute specific to this type of Junction
that you're looking at so ultimately the
departures from standards couldn't
couldn't be overcome they're too many
for them all to be overcome what other
options were looked out other than
signals through chairman of course the
applicant has put this forward and we're
assessing what has been put before us
it's up to them obviously to consider
the options the rank back is the obvious
alternative provision you haven't wanted
cooping system a left in left out the
complication we have here is is levels
of it's a slit rotor coming in so really
it did lead itself to a signals position
ultimately it's in the net
position but ultimately it was a matter
for the applicants whose des felt that
that was the best option for themselves
our position is to audit does not comply
and that is where they come down on it's
acceptable not whether or not there was
a a better alternative scenario thank
you Joe
okay thank you the HTV management plan
was alluded to by one of our speakers
and whether it being considered robust
enough clearly in your view what I can
only assume in your view it is robust
enough that there won't be a significant
if any impact on a green and studly is
that a correct assessment it's it's a
view that the suitable plan can be put
forward with reporting of enforcement
mitigation behind it but we've left it
as a condition because we want the
applicants to actually propose something
and that'll go through a process when
that's ultimately submitted so nothing's
custom stone at this stage okay
two hundred thousand pounds is not a
substantial amount of money than order
to make changes is there there are no
other suggestions of any form of
financial contribution from developers
which I find peculiar because normally I
will see those do we is there an
opportunity at the reserve massive stage
and is that why I'm not seeing it here
or are we not going to be looking for
any further there is a significant HTV
problem in study that I'm all too aware
of and I think something should be done
for dressing given there's going to be
an increase yeah yeah no two hundred
thousand pounds is the amount that's
been put into the bond unto the 106 and
it's seen as a fallback position we're
hoping that the condition for the HTV
routine will be sufficient and the 200k
will only then be called upon to deal
with any residual matters within the
villages and macabre greens with Liam
anywhere else that things may arise so
ultimately no we don't get another
chance at REM know if the amount is
insufficient now then it needs to be
discussed now while the applicants away
all right Alex my final one talk about
heritage and public view
I'm I'm going to assume again that that
is something that we encompass that
reserve matters this is that's not part
of this application no I mean the only
thing which has come into the assessment
list application is the building Heights
which the developer alluded to in his
speech in terms of the heights have been
reduced through the pre apt stage to
improve the impact on the setting of
Gork at Hall and if I could just pull up
the parameters plan so the provision of
this landscape buffer he I was
incorporated to it to improve the the
impact on the setting obviously through
reserve matters we will be able to
control it more tightly I II will know
the design color specific layout and
conservation and the impact on Gorka all
will be one of the primary
considerations in those reserved matters
submissions but it has still been
obviously considered at this stage in
terms of building heights and what's
appropriate for the parameters of the
development and you're satisfied that
what you put in front of business yes we
consulted with historic England
Bromsgrove conservation officer and
Stratford conservative conservation
officer they've all identifies less than
substantial harm to heritage assets in
terms of the setting primarily of Gorka
Hall which is great two-star listed in
those instances we need to be able to
demonstrate very considerable and great
public benefits outweigh that harm
that's what I've sought to do in the
conclusion section in my view that harm
is outweighed by the benefits of the
scheme and it's the members to determine
whether they agree with that I see that
Riddick are looking at or talking in
terms of speed limit on the f-35 going
through maple grove green of around 13
mph but I'm also concerned about cars
coming up to that run and the traffic
lights you referred to or was discussed
earlier about the fact that you didn't
think a speed limit should be imposed I
would have thought it was important
because traffic can can't rather too
quickly off behind one stopped the red
light I didn't order
has been taken into account on that
behind okay in order to introduce any
speed limits we'd have to have the
support of the police they won't support
any applications for changes to speed
limits if they're not naturally
reinforcing because they haven't got the
resources to go out and actually do lots
of speed tricks as that they tell us so
unless the prevailing speed is in the
area of the the scientists feeling that
is proposed but they won't support it so
unless the prevailing speed is in the
range of 30 miles an hour now there'll
be no sense in actually changing that
speed limit even for safety reasons
coming up - it's not naturally
self-enforcing whatever speed limit you
saw in short to put in a per speed
camera you're probably not going to get
compliance I mean in that instance you'd
be putting up things like signs should
say cues likely ahead Thank You chair
two questions one on highways if I may
um when you've been looking at the HTV
modelling I mean it seems very obvious I
mean as the big distribution part of
this to be a part of this application
most of the lawyers will actually head
north they'll go straight to the m42
because logistics companies don't want
to go through mapable rain or steadily
because it's just not efficient but in
your modelling have you looked at what
the the potential harm might be for
lorries traveling south to the dog oil
injunction and then heading west towards
warwick to actually get to the mm40 at
Longbridge island Junction ten because
that is going to send or potentially
could send a lot of hgv vehicles through
Henley and Arden through Preston Baggett
through Clavin
and beyond to the m-40 it looks like
that could be a sort of rat run I just
wondered how you consider that do you
think it's acceptable on what is you
know an a road it is a turn road but
it's it's a very very narrow Trump
the area that you just described doesn't
completely form part of the area that
was modeled the the actual impacts of
HCV over the dog roundabout was
something that was raised by our road
safety team and that was partly why we
wanted to help HCV routing plan to push
all the HCV movements north we don't
want any lobbyists going down through
that roundabout at all it has enough of
an impact in terms of the main just the
maintenance problems alone that can be
part of the conditions Alice Alice okay
looking at this again there is obviously
a big clash between the height of these
distribution warehouses and the
proximity to residential areas it's
obviously a bit to be pointed out by the
applicant yes the the large part within
our are our districts is flat great well
okay I'm not that bothered about that I
don't bother about is the impact on the
residents I mean is it possible as this
comes forward if this passes mine comes
forward as a detailed application that
we could put in a buffer zone to
actually ensure that the nine meter and
the 15 meter high buildings could be on
the south part of the site so as
minimize the effect on the residents of
winglets
we have to consider the parameters
planners before us are you showing the
employment zones to those heights and
you'll note that there is a buffer
perimeter planting to the south western
boundary of the site to mitigate some of
the visual impact on the dwellings are
far more lane and I think it's important
to note that as council barnes alluded
to earlier this is obviously outlying we
still have to consider the
appropriateness of those heights but it
doesn't mean to say that us accepting
that height across the entirety of the
southern parcel would mean that
subsequent reserved matters would be
acceptable we obviously have to still
have regard to the specific design
layout proximity to neighbors
and we do have that ability to obviously
reassess the appropriateness of that at
a reserve massive stage to ensure the
impact on the
bring immunity and visual immunity is
acceptable picking up on that particular
point is it appropriate therefore to put
a note in that we would like to see that
example it could be even be one I don't
know in that more sensitive area on the
southwest of this site is actually we
can put forward I think we can certainly
put a note on to suggest that
potentially a height of 21 meters across
the entirety of the southern development
site is unlikely to be acceptable I
think that would be reasonable I think
it would be more difficult to start
talking about bringing news classes down
because I think as the developer stated
earlier its anticipated that the B one
uses would be within the northern
section of Jason to gawk at all but
there's no reason why those be a B two
uses can't be accommodated within lower
buildings if we've got justification to
say that anything higher would be
unacceptable we do have to have
obviously a policy basis for that but I
think it's completely reasonable to put
a note on as it's austere for the
developers for the reserved matters
stage and just before I go to councillor
Richards and councillor claret also
mentioned about notes as we're talking
about most at the moment about good
quality of design color materials etc in
landscaping lighting that I appreciate
that we do have as part and parcel of
policy course strategy call it a good
quality design this is an industrial
area it was quite different from housing
however and it's that part and part of
what we've got in your report at the
moment or a condition or does it need to
be added in there's a note at present
the recommendation is just the standards
reserved matters conditions again I
don't think there's any harm to add a
note on to say that a full consideration
needs to be had with regards to that it
was certainly something which was picked
up by the conservation officers that
things such as color lighting design was
going to have to be carefully considered
although the heights have been
considered to be generally acceptable
there is still that reserved matters
stage where we need to think very
carefully about the specific design and
whether that will be acceptable from a
heritage aspect so I think it's
completely reasonable to put a note on
again to help steer develop it
Eliquis thank you for that and counselor
riches did you want to thank chair of
what counsel Auckland has said if we
were minded to refuse the application
how would that impact what has been
granted at the north end of the site as
this is probably a legal question how
would that impact that end we clearly
can't dictate the heights outside of our
own remit so we can't force higher
buildings towards the north would the
north end still be able to be developed
or would a new application have to come
in to encompass the entire site what
would be our legal position oh please if
they just wanted to develop the northern
section in the Bromsgrove district if
this council refused the application
before you they would need a new
application just to Bromsgrove they
wouldn't be able to implement the
outline Planning Commission unless it's
approved by all three authorities right
now mentioned about noise and I must
admit it is one most frustrating and
annoying things as king beepers going on
at reversing glories at night and
especially if these are going to be
distribution warehouses with traffic how
are we going to mitigate noise and can
we put a condition on that those sort of
things are not used in the evenings I
don't know can we do that in our view we
it would be reasonable for us to
condition that for example you can't use
reversing because nighttime hours and
obviously we haven't got any specific
hours to mind I've just queries with Joe
whether there's any standard wording for
such a condition we don't but I think
it's something that if your happiness
members minded to approve on that basis
we could agree the final wording through
you as chair the the principle is
certainly something which
which we're just picking up on that
particular point if if this committee is
minded to grant approval this evening
then I would recommend that the when it
comes to any of those conditions of
myself and the ward member involved also
when it comes to reserved matters stage
as well obviously that is something that
that particular point now obviously that
could be in the future so I think it'd
just be a state a statement that he will
come back it's going to come back to
this committee reserve matters you got
to come back to us anyway
so it's simply that the the ward member
is fully engaged on that particular
process right one of the residents
mentioned about increased car movements
as opposed to a teepee we've been
focusing a little bit on TVs can you
please confirm that obviously you've
considered the vehicle movements as well
called car movements and the potential
impact obviously where people are gonna
come from to work on this society yeah
Warwickshire actually took the step of
building a new strictly romics model to
assess the impacts through strictly
because of the concerns that were there
for the a for three four five corridors
through struggling mother'll grain so
all the traffic that will come to them
from on that corridor was modelled
you've got the essentially it is it is a
relatively low percentage that are
coming from the south most of the
workforce are looking forecast to be
coming from redditch from the north and
surrounding areas
thank you no particular point as well
steadily is suffering obviously as we
are wet fully aware with air pollution
and called air quality moving within the
actual villages so it was mentioned by
one of the speakers this evening about
air pollution have we any evidence of
air pollution and how are we going to
monitor it in the future
yeah on that point obviously was
something which was carefully considered
in the application particularly given
that steadily is designated as an air
college quality management area I've
consulted with Stratford's Environmental
Health Department and autobuses regular
tree services was to show a generally
happy I was if they don't have any air
qmf within the vicinity of the site in
their patch in terms of Stratford
obviously like to say we've got the
study aqm a and environmental house were
happy or were content to raise no
objection that was on the basis that the
conditions include the requirement to
control HTV movements to the development
as well as from and also the requirement
for annual reports to be submitted to
environmental health so often Roy got
the condition details requiring surveys
so just that would be written into the
condition that it submitted both
counting highways and also environmental
health to look from an air quality
perspective thank you are there any
other technical questions that you would
like to raise council bonds the school
and the others about crossing it does
appear to be obviously a lot more
traffic they're going to be stood still
other people and get across the road or
is there going to be somewhere safe for
them to get across the road where there
is a need okay as I understand it so in
the existing problems the objector
raised and they're already looking at
measures in conjunction with Graham
Stanley who works in safer routes to
school team in Warwickshire and the
police so I would have expected if
there's an existing problem on the
network that the traffic and road safety
team will have to work to solve that
issue it's not been demonstrated that
the volume of traffic that coming from
this development is going onto the audio
it is for either it is for existing
problems on the network so we can only
look at the impacts of this development
we've got our core strategy in place
as bronze they've got their call
strategy in place and in that are they
having do they have the same can't make
the same comments about this site as we
do yes so just to confirm this site is
allocated in both Stratford's plan
bronze grows plan and redditors plans
and it's as part of joint working to
provide employment and supply for
Redditch and it's been identified as
essentially the most suitable site for
us to help them meet their employment
needs I think your members in the
respective Paul the traffic that just go
through there
we're in a difficult position because
this is already sort of gone through
part of the planning system and it is in
the core strategy I I am concerned about
the design in the respect of the height
of the buildings the buildings are not -
in my eyes too close to the residential
properties the nori smell and that sort
of thing if the conditions that we has
put on as that line a good enough to
counteract that when it comes to detail
plan I could support it but I have I
have concern and those concerns I think
yeah not so I've broken that it's
positioning really of the big buildings
to 90 meters we're in the core strategy
they do give a guide well but with good
conditions I could support it will be
narrow it up to review
thank you sure and as counsel bonds has
pointed out the principle of development
on this site has already been granted
through course Russia sits through three
core strategies so inevitably it will
happen at some stage in some form but
what we've got to do now is consider it
and get it right when we do I have great
concern over the traffic management yep
the access orbit it appears from our
from our experts this is the only
solution but more importantly the
movement away from the site if we were
looking at and say housing development
on here we'd be having an enormous sum
of money to put towards road
improvements around the network that
will be an that will be impacted we
still have a significant amount of
traffic movement coming from this site
yet we've got 200,000 pounds it is just
not enough in my view I don't think that
impact has been sufficiently dealt with
I certainly have no evidence to suggest
that it has been sufficiently dealt with
so on that basis I have I minded now too
to refuse the application on that basis
I am interested to hear what other
councillors have to say I may be swayed
but at the moment I'm I don't think
that's sufficient and it needs to be
considered in more depth and it's a
valid point I think it was highways who
asked for that sum of money so should I
ask them I always have got it wrong
before let's ask them now because
obviously it may be something we can
take away in defer for example and then
we can come back and look at that one at
a at a point but was that just the sum
of when you asked for and what basis did
you ask okay I understand it the amount
of money that was requested was based on
a similar situation we had with dr3 over
in rugby and that was a sum of money
there that was in a bond to call on and
provide mitigation for residual impacts
if the main conditions haven't addressed
things so the idea is it's only there as
a safety net if other things fail
which is all well and good but I don't
know whether we're drawing on similar
comparisons I don't know anything about
three whatever it was in rugby it could
well be an isolated field in the middle
of nowhere here we have a huge amount of
land that is surrounded by residences
there is going to be a significant
impact we know already from work that
County Council have done that there is
already an HTV problem and steadily
we don't appear to have addressed it and
this is an opportunity for us to do that
what we're actually doing in my view is
compounding the issue by putting another
park industrial park up the road from it
the only thing I can say that is
obviously we're not anticipating excuse
me the HDB's to be a problem to himself
because the lobby routine plan should
prevent anything but that happening so
it should all go north to the motorway
in terms of d'oeuvre three it's a huge
employment site over near the m1 and
four to drive interchange at Rugby with
the rail head and it's got the halt and
mass site for six thousand houses being
developed of just to the west of it I
can just sort of clarify point I think
the issue is contributions towards
highways has come up a lot to do with
existing problems which are evident in
macro green and instead Lee and I think
the difficulty here is that we can
obviously only mitigate against any
additional harm which arises as a result
of this development so that's the view
that highways have come from they've
looked at this development they've
modeled it and they've come up with the
view that the only financial
contribution that is required as a
result of any harm which is could
potentially arise from this development
is the need for this two hundred
thousand pounds I think we we all
probably agree that other measures may
be required to fix existing problems but
this application isn't the means by
which we can do that and ensure that
financial contributions are still
compliant I completely understand and
accept that as a the point I made is
there are already problems I'm asking
those problems to be fixed we are trying
to address those as
both with Walsh County Council and
strategist rank the District Council
we're trying to address those this
compounds the issue there is a
significant increase in the number of
HGVs are going to be using these roads
whilst yes we can put some form of
management into them turning left or
right out of the development and onto
the a 435 we can't guarantee it they
will go whichever way they're sat-nav
tells them to go that is why as part of
the condition all of the measures and
proposals in the enforcement are going
to have to be spelled out it as a
condition it would be nice to have had
it here now so you could have any
because I'm and a it's a bit like gain
like on Heath in the treatment of the p4
100 the information isn't there so it
serve as a condition and it needs to
it'll need to be satisfied to make sure
that all the lorries will come out the
site they will use that the rich to go
to him from north when will that happen
what that will be up to the applicant as
if they were to get a consent as to when
they submit to discharge that condition
and that we are if we're not happy with
that condition we just send you back and
say because obviously as before the
reserve matters stage it's got to be
within it would be prior to first
occupation so not necessarily before
reserve matters but before any
businesses they're occupying the site we
need to have had agreed with them a
specific strategy in terms of hdhd be
routing customers I don't think we can
would actually do that once we've got
what we've agreed in highway I've got
two applications and you know well we
can't get always to agree to this and
that and
and the add client permission has gone
through now is the time to get it right
and I don't think it is right and I'm
quite happy to delay it or amend it or
whatever you know can I just ask you to
elaborate a little bit on that
particular point why your what your
concerns are on a particular point I'm
concerned about is that once we've
agreed this we have got no power on what
does actually happen on on the road
because it isn't detailed enough it
isn't fine enough for us to know exactly
what he's going they say oh well if we
want to cross him or laughter ask the
safety people well that to me is not a
lot of good we've got all those hundreds
of ossie they're having to go to school
across the road no thoughts in the
design as far as I can see has been
being designed it's ain't good enough
for me and because we've had it before
where the County Council and then when
we come to it we have a junction we've
got up the road which is 2.5 meters boy
Loren stars and everybody can't get
through so when we come to the detail
plan I said all the hard way there we've
been agreed just bear with me for one
moment please well I have a brief
discussion on this point
thank you everybody
apologies for that but we do need to try
and get these things bottled out if you
know I do Joe can I just ask the routing
strategy which seems to be one quite
legitimately concern of burn of a couple
of members here first of all why haven't
we got one now that's one of the
questions how robust is it now I
appreciate that we cannot tell every
driver which way to go but how can you
ensure as much as you can but they will
go the correct path go north of the the
435 and how long would it take to get
robust documents to us okay and the
reason we haven't got one now is that
some indicative types of measures and a
routing plan that could have been
introduced but there's nothing concrete
we actually want to know what is being
proposed for us to either say yeah you
were made to in terms of the types of
measures that might be in there we would
expect a plan to say that lorries will
route and use for these particular
routes we want that to be there by
condition and under the 106 so that it
lives with the lease holders on those
sites so that as people go in and out of
these units they will all be obligated
to adhere do the same provisions
measures that could be proposed and it
will be for the applicants to put
forward a list for us to consider and
assess it could include tracking of
vehicles lots of HTV operators these
days actually track live so they know
exactly where their lorries are on the
network and are they going to get to
their destination in that time slot that
they've been allocated we could
obviously look to use a and P our
cameras will they'll be as a requirement
for them to do annual surveys so that we
can assess and see what's going where so
those are the types of things that would
be there but it will be up for the
applicants to propose what they consider
to be suitable sounds great when they're
ignored by the drivers who's going to
enforce it and at what cost the cost
would be to the district in the county
because that would take office a time
there wouldn't be a trrs which I won't
be police enforcement and it would be
for us to enforce either under the
planning condition or legally under the
106 the legal agreement there so under
planning condition of course the
District Council and that would be the
first port call yeah the contribution
you're going to get will go to the
county so we're gonna have to enforce on
something that actually the members
around this table don't appear to be
comfortable with actually there's no
money there for enforcement
unless it's proposed as part of the I'm
still unconvinced that safe having a
short of having that confirmed concrete
document that tells me tells us how
manage now how the traffic is going to
be managed and when it falls short of
that management how it's going to be
enforced ensure it's enforced and if it
doesn't still doesn't work how that
200,000 pounds is going to be justified
as a suitable contribution in order to
put it right I'm not satisfied and I'm
not prepared to accept this and grant
this application I am prepared to
propose we defer pending that
information I would rather not refuse at
this point given we're at this stage I
would propose we defer pending that
information and if that's not supported
then I'm entirely happy to go through a
refusal
well I'm quite happy to support that and
I think that's the appropriate authority
because I'm sort of mentioned it before
because I think that's the only way
forward right all we do go down that
route there's obviously a few other
things that come out
the discussions debates and technical
questions for example the notes etc some
of the conditions about noise I'm going
to make a suggestion that we actually
roll those all of the other including
what you've discussed about the traffic
management plan and then they can be
brought forward at the appropriate time
you're going to have to elaborate on
what you mean by that because deferring
because there might be noise isn't
sufficient I'm happy to defer based on
the fact we have insufficient
information on traffic management and to
support the contribution that's been
requested you'll need to elaborate on
the other points before we agree to
anything I think what I was just after
clarification on that point is what you
want us to go away and do so do you want
them to be submitting an HTP routing
strategy to be agreed by all parties so
that when we then bring it back to
committee that conditions essentially
discharged is that what it's all intent
and purpose yeah short of having that
information understanding exactly how
this is going to work I'm entirely
uncomfortable subjecting that area to an
increase in HDTV movements and I also
want to understand that if how it's
enforced by whom and if there is still a
framing in that management plan how that
200,000 pound is justified in its way in
an appropriate contribution order to
address the impact that this is going to
have there can't be much more concise
about it enough 200,000 pounds is
adequate that's why I said you can
sponsor because I don't think at this
stage we need to concern about the
height of the building because they have
the applicants have heard what we are
concerned and I think when it comes back
I hopefully it will be right he prefers
Portland Council
thank you chair yeah I completely agree
with councillor Richards on the highways
that I am not satisfied are neither
satisfied about the financial
contribution we just haven't got enough
information so I'm more than happy to -
it's a second the proposal to defer but
what I would also ask was my
earlier that when this comes back again
we're not objecting to the uses
employment but I would like to see the
note that I was talking about about when
it comes back to have some sort of
guidance on where the tall buildings
gonna be on the site and their
relationship to the residential
properties at winnards agree with and I
agree with counsel Rich's we've the
traffic plan is a and the lack of money
are very important I also feel that the
southwest corner of the site as well
where the main resident residents are
should be property and give more
detailed approach and also I'm concerned
about the school and the children going
to school which is at the southern end
of the site I think money should be made
available or some sort of arrangement
with the developers to make sure there's
a bridge or some means of getting
children safely across the road I think
that would have to be examined
separately simply because it's an
existing issue and it would be on
Dorothea of the department which is a
safer routes to school which apparently
has been looked at so I think that would
be something for plenty consider however
members the vote before you they have a
proposal in a second can I Alice would
you I'm sure I saw a slide where there
was an indication of where buildings and
car parking that's going to go could you
bring it to that please so it's a
council Orton's point about the layout
and endi indication of where the
builders are going to go is that in
front of us now pretty much concrete of
what we're gonna see no so that could
completely change those buildings could
be in complete different alignment Thank
You members the vote or used to defer
item 1701 84 7th started out with the
notes that we've agreed and also the
be produced okay anything else at happy
okay the boat before you is that members
all those in favor of deferring item
1701 eight foursome subshell thank you
this committee therefore resolved to
defer item seventy so one eighty four
seven star out thank you I'll take a
five-minute break now thank you
the site is located off the snitterfield
Road and is outlined in red on the plan
it is accessed a lot of Drive of
approximately 500 meters in length from
the main road the site itself is located
within an ancient semi natural woodland
in addition to the east of the site and
to the south of the site by the
snitterfield and bailey bushes which are
sites a specific scientific interest
this is an aerial view of the site with
the applications records the site
roughly outlined in red here we have the
existing and proposed site layout the
slide on the left is the existing layout
and members will note the black outline
of the existing building on the site on
the right hand side we have the proposed
layout with plot one to the southeast
and plot two to the northwest members
will also note The Associated driveways
and hard standing this is a more
detailed site layout plan showing plots
one and two with the associated workshop
to the right-hand side these are the
existing elevations of the building on
the site to be demolished here we have
the elevations of proposed plot one with
the floor plans illustrating a four
bedroom dwelling which is a single story
and with basement accommodation to be
provided
here we have the elevations of plot T
and the floor plans show that this is a
five bedroom dwelling with accommodation
spread across two floors we now have
some photos of the site here we stood at
the entrance to the site on the
snitterfield Road looking up the access
Drive standing at the access we're
looking west along the centerfield road
which leads to bearly we're now standing
within the application site with the
existing buildings behind us members
will note the access Drive which is in
the middle of the photo which stretches
all the way down to the main highway
this is the existing building on the
site which is to be demolished what one
is to be constructed in the approximate
location we are now looking slightly to
the left of the existing building in the
open area of land where plot 2 is
proposed and this is panning further
around site with the woodland on the
periphery standing will slightly further
down the access Drive looking back
towards the application site we can see
part of the existing building on the
right what one would be on the left
where the existing building is and plot
2 it'd be on the left the existing
building is now on the left-hand side
just outside of the photo and we're
looking towards the open area of land
that will be in front of plot 2 and I'll
have a video
so this video pans across the whole site
this is looking from where plot would be
located panning across to the existing
building where plot two would be located
we're going around the entirety of the
site members will note the woodland in
the background there are a couple of
updates the application Clara finds and
typos within the officer report as
detailed on the update sheet chairman
the recommendation is to refuse the
application for the four reasons set out
on pages 93 and 94 of the agenda thank
you right we don't have any parish
speakers this evening so our first
speaker this evening is Oliver Spicer
and Jane Bartlett
one of the spices is this chamber at the
applicant really remembers the
application as said by officers a
resubmission of the earlier scheme for
four dwellings this committee and the
consensus at the time was a scheme of
two to a lien to be much more
appropriate would reflect the character
of the area been within the woodland
this proposed at least of two to aliens
separated by new landscaping between the
dwellings on the footprint of the
building to be demolished the
application isn't in coordinate with
paragraph 89 of the MPP F which is for
redevelopment of green bound where an
existing building structure is and the
proposals of no greater impact in this
instance that's the size and scale of
the buildings so the new dwellings are
less in volume and less in footprint
there's over an acre of higher standing
of concrete to be removed from that
central area the considerable benefit to
this scheme the parish council here
tonight and ward members support its
application and if the previous scheme a
lot of the people in the village do also
and I did ask for a presentation any
metope just put up tonight it's possible
I'm on the presentation now just a
couple of slides as hopeful to show you
on the left-hand slide the diagram
illustrates the former RAF base on the
site in 1945 this is in English aerial
photograph from near initial archives
you can see there that because it were a
number of buildings in the area we are
proposing on the aerial photograph
second from the left you'll see the
buildings are still present at that
point in 2010 huge amount burns have
been removed but the area of highest
families considerable on the far
right-hand side imposed on their
overhead scheme there will see the
develop we're proposing which reduces
any impact really and takes away at much
of the Heartland in the concrete in the
building's as a huge reduction it's it's
on the next slide if possible you'll see
only existing building as comparison
from the same viewpoint you can move to
the final slide you'll see this is
or proposal watching to be there there's
a significant improvement in this
proposal on what was there previously in
the reduction in the green part
so hopefully urges not to to support its
application thank you Thank You members
there any questions you would like to
ask Katherine cancel fielding what's the
current use of the building and is it
actually in use or they've been
redundant for a while and the currently
uses the one and I use it pretty much
solely at the moment for the running of
our business which has downscaled quite
significantly in a number of years it's
it's a luxury it's a huge overhead for
one person to to work in that building
counseling if I can give you some
history first of all when we first
acquired the property some 20 years ago
we had a fledgling business that was
rocketing we we have an exhibition and
event company at that time we had
offices and studios in Stratford we
needed which we don't grow so we
acquired that site and used it
predominantly as offices ancillary
offices sorry workshop and storage areas
in recent years we have downscale quite
significantly my husband has become
semi-retired he's actually partially
disabled and now I pretty much run it
single-handedly
and so by out all day what we used to
all the production work we know SEP all
that I own just project knowledge
effectively I can do that from anywhere
from a laptop so as I say it's conclude
that it's worth noting that for a number
of years they've tried to sell the
property as a commercial asset and
there's been no interest whatsoever to
both let it or to buy the property this
is when we were engaged in the project
thank you cassabaum see you thank you I
did that click on a short visit with
before this not bad question you I was
expecting but the wood was dead it
wasn't a bird there squirrels
Topsy smelt would you be willing to put
bird boxes in your as the new
development is that and I have done this
for the Garden City along marked in
different size bricks for different
birds I would like to see if this
application
absolutely it's something we've noticed
in the design access statement the
fabrics they're called so bricks that
have kind of holes and insulation and
which are out and multiple species to
utilize them along with in the woodland
thank you very much Bailey Parish
Council apologize they did intend to be
here chairman but unfortunately they
didn't register in time and they have
given me a note which I will read that's
okay I think I'll probably get it within
the five minutes like okay thank you
so this is the parish council statement
the parish council support this
application based on planning policy and
sound reasoning as the development is to
redevelop a brownfield site that's in
poor condition and becoming a physical I
saw the council believe it supports the
principle development and Court of
thorns with paragraph 18 under the NPP F
and supports of design the new dwellings
the Parish Council proactively supports
but they seek condition to ensure the
woodland management plan form as part of
the approval right that's me
the report is very thorough it basically
goes down to the openness of the
Greenbelt and here we are again this
came before the committee some months
ago as for buildings it's now down to
which was I think what we were looking
for the site is 8090 percent green at
the moment with an ugly 10,000 square
for 1941 builder / dative aircraft it's
got no commercial future to replace this
with two reasonably sized homes smaller
and less intrusive than the existing
structure can only to my mind and
hopefully the members might improve the
openness I mean how could we argue
against this sustainability the argument
is it's a not a sustainable solution
theory is in general unsustainable it's
a great big long road with all sorts of
houses dotted about a train that doesn't
stop you need to go to Wellman coat to
get the claim back to severely and
there's a wholly useless bus service it
can be successfully argued that any
development in the village is
unsustainable on this basis and any
other village around it is unsustainable
- you just need to own a car to get it
back in Warwickshire rural villages so
the unsustainable argument I just don't
get on page 33 it states that this
project would cause a poor connect
between people and places there's no
other viable option now paragraph 55 of
the MPP F special circumstances we're
saying there are actually officers well
the reason this is a case of the use of
a brownfield site which occurred to a
core strategy s10 paragraph 55 of the MP
FF says that youths are redundant or
disused buildings is a special
circumstance surely where there's no
possible chances it's 1941 aircraft
hanger being converted to any other use
it's demolition and reuse a much needed
housing in Bailey must be a relevant
exception again within para 54 another
reason is in respect to the exceptional
quality and design looking at the design
of these buildings ok design is personal
these are nice modern well-designed
buildings I like the idea that some of
the accommodation is in the basement
again it's it's it's making the impact
less by having accommodation below
ground and recently this council has had
a decision
now on a similar type of building and
note in Clarendon overturned at appeal
because part of the building was in the
basement now a viable enterprise and
this isn't a viable enterprise it says
ended up in the forties it's a ninth one
aircraft hangar as a commercial netting
opportunity it's completely wrong to
consider it has any economic or business
future if the officers report claims
that this is a lot of employment
opportunity this officer has obviously
no knowledge of the commercial nettings
market which I do so it's the only
possible use of this brownfield site for
residential can't be used for anything
else the options are to actually pass
this will just let the building rot into
the ground that's up to members it has
the support of the Parish Council which
I think weighs very heavily they've
supported it in the past they're
supporting it now and there's no
credible objection so let's grant
consent Thank You councillor to
questions percent wind to the viability
of the business
we obviously heard from both yourself
and our speakers prior to you that it's
no longer a viable business to succeed
in business and that an attempt has been
made to either sell all that out have
you seen any evidences for that because
unfortunately at the moment I'm not
seeing every of any evidence no it's the
answer I I've not seen any evidence but
I would stress councillor Richards that
with my commercial experience if you
were to try to sell this or let it as a
commercial enterprise you're not going
to find any takers
it's a dilapidated drafty building I'm
in fair play to the applicant they have
made it look a little bit more
acceptable but if you look at this site
properly the building is past its
economic use you should see round the
back and in terms of the appropriateness
and special circumstances you suggested
there was a special circumstance I'm
trying to understand what it was I
you were talking so quickly I missed it
well the special circumstance is that
this is a brownfield site and it is very
unusual site in limits half a kilometre
from the main road the majority of this
site is basically grass and trees with
this dirty grey big aircraft hangar
stuck at the back which nobody can see
unless you're a particularly poor golfer
on the second hold at the golf go if you
go you won't be able to see it from
there but it's hardly noticeable and
quite quite frankly these lower lower
rise buildings you won't be able to see
them at all it'll have no impact in my
view so the special circumstance is that
it is a joke bonafide a brownfield site
and we're allowed to build housing on
brownfield sites surely the presumption
should be that we should be producing
houses that are much needed in barely on
this site and the other the other one
was yeah I mean it's just that the
building has no economic future it's
it's just gonna live forever and rot
gotta do something with it it's too low
it's it looks more like it was a sort of
ammunition or workshop but it is a
banfield site and apart from the usage
have you considered any other uses to it
than what's currently useful I can
answer it I can answer as a chartered
surveyor commercial severa I wouldn't
take that as an agent I'd have to say to
the client
no I'm not gonna waste your time any
other questions okay thank you rooms
Carson
right technical questions and obviously
this is a green area that we're talking
about brownfield in and so both the call
strategy policy cs10 and the MPP F
disgusts redevelopment of brownfield
sites and the Greenbelt and it does
allow for redevelopment of previously
developed sites where the redundant or
in continuing use which would not have a
greater impact on the openness of the
Greenbelt and the definition of
previously developed land in the
glossary of the MPPs also refers to the
fact that so I'm just trying to find the
element it says it should not be assumed
that the whole of the curse lid should
be developed when it's previously
developed land ok thank you and picking
up on the viability have you been
explored with the applicant about
viability and and so the application was
supported with just a copy of the
opponent sales particulars and know and
such pricing was put on those sale
particulars and no justification or
statement as to how long the property's
being marketed for and what price it's
being marketed at and no details of any
inquiries to that marketing have been
submitted and if any offers have been
submitted just put that in into a little
bit of context
to consider this proposal as meeting the
requirements of brownfield land or to
look at the issues surrounding the the
viability of the site is putting the
cart before the horse
tonight German we don't have any
evidence of the nature of marketing the
length of marketing the type of interest
that's been had we don't know that so we
can't make safe decisions on it it's
just taking one part of the argument
that's all we're trying to exactly
remember stick to side thank you for
that thank you still questions patients
such as agree I agree with what's just
been said but I also don't think that we
are doing that if we were looking at the
partial or complete redevelopment of a
previously developed brownfield site
whether it done their own continuing use
it fits a criteria that is permitted in
the Greenbelt although I do agree we
haven't had sufficient supporting
evidence to suggest that marketing
hasn't been undertaken notwithstanding
that could you give me an indication of
the size so the height of the existing
building and its footprint versus the
height of the proposed buildings and its
and their footprint the above-ground
footprint and say the height of the
existing building is nine point one
meters to the ridge and four point six
meters to the eaves and the area of it
is 37 meters by 18 meters
hopefully give you the footprint bear
with me a moment and so the existing
building total footprint and is 723
square meters so plot one has a maximum
height of four point four meters and a
footprint of 516 square meters plot two
has a height of six point two meters and
a footprint of 288 square meters did you
want to
we do assume this is a private land and
and and I think it's okay to develop to
this extent on this side what are the
other arguments against it there seem to
be arguments that even though we're
building on brownfield land that doesn't
mean you can build on this particular
profile and because of sustainability
where does that come in to policy and so
the site is outside of any built
apparent boundaries of any settlements
where new housing and is thought to be
located within the core strategy so it
is considered to be an unsustainable
location for new housing and do you want
to go through the other reason what just
specifically it downfield will encourage
some very field but so this was not
viable at all if this was just
brownfield land in the middle of the
wood there were no other arguments we
would still be and it wasn't surrounded
by a by a 12-8 of wood or whatever it's
called and there wasn't any impact on
that it was brand filled land in this
situation and there were no other
factors we would still be recommending
refusal on sustainability grounds well I
think that's a slightly difficult
question to answer because the
application before us has quite a few
other site constraints and ultimately if
this light had no other constraints then
a balancing argument balancing exercise
would have to be made if we were
satisfied on on all the other grounds
that there was no of the use of the site
there was no harm to the green bow there
was no harm to any ecology or ancient
woodland then a balancing assessment
would have to be made but and we're not
in in that position and officers that
haven't come to that conclusions can you
point me to the RCS member on
on that particular bit of it in terms of
Greenbelt policy sustainability and so
the NCS 15 in CS 16 and talk about and
distribution of development across the
district and a s10 can I just pick up on
that point in the that is a decision
this committee made last time it says
about the brownfields scientists says
that the brownfield is not considered to
meet the green bag exception test and
it's not yeah the so the proposed
development lies within the Greenbelt
obviously the entirety of the redline
areas if it is not considered be
brownfield and therefore not considered
to meet with the Greenbelt exception
test of redevelopment of brownfield land
and yes it is considered that and the
redline area includes larger parts of
the site that the tart brownfield
offices or as a storage I'm not entirely
sure and what the actual internal layout
is and I believe that there may be some
some office space to facilitate the the
use of the sites and maybe some storage
space so would think it feels to be
retained there would be an increased
traffic if we were going to retain it as
a need for existing uses which were then
throws problems on the on the roads in
the area
well and we're not we're assessing the
application before us which is for the
removal of that they are doing the
highways movements may be lesser
associated with two dwellings than the
existing use at the moment okay any
other questions so therefore in the way
I'm looking at it is a brown it is a a
building that doesn't have a great deal
of use at the present moment and will
probably be better treated as changing
it over to the proposal as per the
application there's also a lot of
concrete there that is create a lot of
the question please sorry am i again
it's the concrete area part of the
brownfield site and so if i zoom in on
this plan
so the black area and outlined is the
existing building and then the gray
elements are part of the existing heart
standing so development would go built
development would go beyond those areas
of hard standing okay Casavant
i was just waiting busy discussion
because I've been on the site I'm happy
for you to go into discussion thank you
yes I've been on the site visit the barn
sort of was used I think the storage
there was some pallets and there was
some sleeper petitions in it I think
it's in my eyes was rotundum many years
ago in the respective it would cost a
fortune to put it into b1 or b2 used for
health and safety reasons the roof was
sort of a semi sort of asbestos and
obviously one time with all the other
concrete that's there on the right-hand
side they would have you know the
Americans would have a quite a big place
there it says the reason for refusal
isn't in open countryside but it's in
the middle of a wood so as far as I'm
concerned these two small houses lived
there large houses but they're
substantially smaller than the imprint
of what was there I could fully support
it could cycle to the station I I can't
see I think it's the obvious choice to
move forward before we were concerned
about some trees coming down and an old
tract I suppose it was a it wasn't a
tank track but it was some sort of track
which needed preserving and as far as
I'm concerned I would be quite happy to
propose this application to go forward
but he just need some livestock help the
wood was gay it was quiet
you couldn't hear anything well it shows
me is some birds there and I believe
this has each to has is put in cut
enchants enhance that and I'm quite
happy to propose approval thank you
building the balance on that there's a
lot of concrete down there that is no
use I can't see with the last thing one
needs is a whole lot of storage
buildings or storage containers being
put in there to make it viable I think
it's much better off as a residential
Erik's brownfield and there's a wood to
hide it from the surrounding area I
can't see anything wrong with it
okay because it does need probably birds
and other animals in there but my
feeling is that it should go forward as
we've granted cancer carriage yeah I
loved the buildings I really do
I wish I could support it but I can't
because they're really nice buildings
and I'm very jealous if whoever ends up
living in something like that in the
future either here or somewhere else but
we haven't had the information required
in policy on unemployment we've had
opinions which might very well be
correct but we haven't had the proof and
there's a hell of a lot of concern on
ecology which may be able to be
mitigated but there's nothing about it
here so
you know if it comes back with without
evidence and some mitigation or some
proof that mitigation isn't needed then
you know I'd love to approve this I
don't think it's it's I don't think it's
a Greenbelt issue but I just haven't got
the the paperwork to say yes to it the
general principle of courage is just
said I completely agree with I don't
think I in my mind this is very much a
brownfield site and should be or can be
redeveloped and I actually always going
to answer questions the offices before
we've moved too quickly for me so I'm
asking now why do we need proof of
existing use not being viable anymore in
this instance surely we all have a right
to just put application in and we can
switch I just want to clarify from
clarity on that and policies cs20 to the
core strategy looks at retaining
employment and employment sites and we
need to be satisfied that the site is no
longer viable and for another business
or commercial use and the applicants
have stated that there is capacity for
potentially 30 employers on the site and
we have to and be satisfied at a loss of
that amount would be acceptable in
accordance with verse 22 yes thank you
sorry I know we've done this before and
others I just couldn't get my head round
why right now regrettably and on that
basis I thing in my mind is gonna
prevent us from granting tonight and
we've obviously had a proposal has
happened already failing that I would
propose that we do ago with the officers
recommendation refused
but I wanted made clear that I don't
agree with bullet point - and I don't
agree with bullet point four so it's
really in my mind it's only number three
that's that they'll have to go through
the first but you can only do that but
that's my that's my phone on one that
name well I'll have to be honest and say
I agree with yourself because it carries
on this I don't actually looking at them
the notice of refusal this committee
made which was on the 6th of January
sorry April my apologies so but the it
has been some movement and he's gone
down before which we considered the
overdevelopment on that side but there's
still the other things there which are
the the impact on the Greenbelt and all
the other areas the issues that have not
been my view being overcome and the
other thing we do have to be careful and
I appreciate what counsel all concerned
about here we are again with the
Greenbelt we do need to burn the stand a
little bit more about green burn us
being that's in hand now because I think
we are we do need some more not just
guidance but play studies and some
examples of where it is appropriate at
this moment I can't support this I agree
also in something about the brownfield
product cycling is an element of this
site so I think that should be
remembered as well right are there any
more in that case we have a proposed
from a seconder announced through a
grant planning permission for this item
so members the condition oh yes what
conditions did you want to impose on
this
you wanted a bird box or something can
you look at item four in the of the
regional produce or some place and your
agenda can you have a look at item four
in the reasons to refusal
I think the question on being suggested
to me is if you wish to reverse that
item as something that you wish to to
happen to see happen yeah we are in
agreement on the conditions the wording
will be delegated to officers you're
happy with that okay so members the vote
before use to grant a plan permission
417 such a five nine two cycle all those
in favor all those against abstain thank
you this that proposal therefore fails
do I have a proposal for thee I've got a
proposal for Council Richards second
cancer carriage the Evoque people used
to refuse plan function for 17025 nine
to start all all those in favor against
thank you this committee fought
therefore resolved to refuse planning
permission for 17025 mile 2/4 thank you
can you please make sure that
the next item on the agenda 1702 375
sighs for which the Victoria works
instead Li and the presenting officer is
David when you already loaded
apologies for that minor I tiara yes
thank you chairman the sighting question
it is a public house named Victoria
works it's in within a northern area of
the main rural center of Studley it's
within the built-up area boundary of the
village yeah apologies this is not
working
yeah we might need a brief recess so we
can that's all what's wrong with the
computer apologies so a short break and
get the year get the equipment working
apologies for this letter
okay
Thank You chairman okay so the site is a
public house and associated car park
known as currently known as the Victoria
works formerly the nags head it's
located within a northern area of the
main rural center of studly it's within
the built-up area boundary as a bit of a
zoomed in version the site the site is
the section in the middle here denote by
the red line this little red rectangle
is a grade 2 listed building which we'll
see a little bit can you don't want to I
don't a risk an IT issue I can do I
could do this it's not a vast great
improvement but the this next slide is
hopefully a bit more visible anyway so
it shows the pub in the center of the
slide with the carpark to the rear and
Studley sports ground is just to the
left on the image and you've got the
grade 2 listed building which is known
as number 29 31 redditch Road and it's
also of note that there are two existing
pubs within close proximity to the
application site to the northwest of the
application site is an area of probably
late 20th century housing similarly to
the south east
I think it's called Crandon close
the proposal is to demolish the public
house and undertake some works to alter
the sight levels and to erect nine
Wellings four of which plots one to four
with front redditch road as you can see
on the bottom of this slide since the
proposed site layout so you've got plots
one to four at the top that you saw in
the previous slide and plus five to nine
at the rear the parking area that would
serve the dwellings is located centrally
on a broadly the same locations to
parking in the existing parking area for
the pub and it is of note that County
highways haven't submitted any
objections with regards to the car
parking or access provision the
elevations of plots one two for its note
note that there's no actual windows in
the side elevations there and these are
the plots that front the highway at
Redditch Road so the floor plan so plots
ones are all three-bedroom dwellings
with kitchen living room dining room
ground-floor and bedrooms at first and
within the loft space second floor level
this is plots five to nine so these are
the ones that are at the rear of the
site the two dwellings on either side
one bedroom bungalows I'm just trying to
circle them there and the dwellings the
three terraced Wellings in the center
two-story obviously and they're
two-bedroom dwellings this is the
proposed site levels hopefully you can
make out that line there is the existing
site levels so it is proposed to be
terraced
lowered slightly and you can see on this
one here that sort of pinkish gray area
there is the built form of the existing
pub so the proposed dwellings at the
front of the site would actually not
extend as far back into the site in
terms of the depth and
the existing perp onto photos this is
the pub with the access existing access
to the side that's going to remain
utilized for the proposed dwellings it's
another view of the pub and if a
neighboring property here that split
into flats there's some views from the
carpark here so I'll start with this
this photograph that's the rear of the
pubs you can see that the carpark is
actually quite elevated that's of view
northwest showing the rear boundary
shared with the sports ground this is a
view north showing some of the existing
trees along the boundary they're
actually just outside the site boundary
and that's the rear just to let's see at
the bottom that's the rear of the
property at 37 and 37 a red each Road
that is is split into two flats the last
photograph is a view south east again
showing trees that line the site
boundary just outside this is a
photograph of the great enlisted
building from the carpark just about
make out that it is actually again on a
lower ground level from the carpark in
the access level and that's a view of
the Grade II listed building from
redditch Road so you can see it's set
back quite far into the site and it's
over time been surrounded by more modern
development these are some neighbouring
dwellings two at the top probably late
19th century early 20th century and they
front directly onto reddit's road and
the dwellings at the bottom are the mid
to late 20th century dwellings I do have
a couple of videos to show I don't know
if it's necessary to show them and I
think they have car registrations in
them so Ross I was going to ask if that
is something that could be an issue
normally on photographs we redact car
registration so it's not necessary yeah
he did yeah if it's unnecessary to show
the videos that is one of the carpark
one of the site access but like
hopefully the photos are sufficient and
that's the end of the presentation thank
you Jeff little less rushed in this one
obviously this is a an employment site
within the village that unfortunately is
no longer trading and we think the
applicant has gone a long way into
providing what is much needed in the
village which is family homes however we
think the natural design of the premises
is a little overbearing on the site it
is cramped the access into the Sarge is
quite difficult
although county highway is yet again
they've got it wrong and access into
this is quite difficult it is 30 more
Road and you can't see round the corner
they've been pumps and shunts for years
I see use the pub when it was open and
there's always little bumps people
coming at the car park and nothing is
being done to improve that what the
asked at the time was the applicant
actually bought the buildings at the
front back a couple of metres even a
metre back to create a little more
disability and they would have been
absolutely fine who wouldn't have really
lost any big space on the development
but they've chosen to put an application
in the in his present form we think he's
unacceptable we also concerns over the
retaining wall at the back the backs
onto the sports and social club and
there is a spring lenita sorts of social
club that is well known for causing
flooding on there and you are putting
back into that
underneath this site there is a
reservoir of water under the ground that
causes all sorts of problems for the
factory with the press and so there are
definitely water table issues that we
have concerned with taking that much
soil out of the site could cause issue
so what if it does go ahead it needs
careful conditioning as to what
treatment is given to that retaining
wall to ensure it will stand up a little
hole of the soles behind there because
it goes up quite a way up it's about
five six meters up when you get the
topper slow so yes in the development
but it could be a lot better designed
and we think if it's refused then a
better application will come forwards
that actually does address issues that
we are concerned with okay thank you
very much caster I'll pick up the point
with regards to the underwater element
and with the officer in a few moments
and we'll discuss that one and pick up
your points incidentally about the
visibility on such time so I'm on the 30
mile now Road I do know that road quite
well
any other questions cattitude I've never
known the pub flood No No thank you very
much thank you our next speaker is Jayne
Cashville with David Niang Dave Mirra
and Rob Evans
right yeah three minutes between you
hello Jane
thanks just as some introductions this
is Dave Neal from the David Tucker
associates the highways consultant and
Rob Evans from design visual who's there
for any questions so Dave and I will be
approximately half and half the time so
I suppose you've heard the site
comprises the Victoria works a pub it's
been closed since spring 2016 after
closing it was marketed by enterprises
for a new tenant but none was found
Enterprise Inns then instructed
Christian Co to market the property for
sale but also failed to find a buyer the
pub was then auctioned in February this
year core strategy policy CS 25
identifies a pub as a community facility
and allows for its loss if one or more
of the criteria room at this development
meets at least three of the four
criteria it should be noted there is no
local objection to the loss of the pub
the development provides a number of
benefits and achieve some aims of the
parish plan these are firstly a good mix
of houses with smaller units secondly
the reuse of brownfield land which
doesn't impact on the Greenbelt
surrounding steadly and thirdly the
removal of the pub and erection of
houses provides a more compatible land
use to the adjoining houses it's
recognised that the parish council
objected to the scheme along with
councillor courage and other third
parties however it should be noted that
there are also six letters of support
and no objections from ecology highways
and public rights-of-way console tees
some of the objections relate to the
slicing of the houses at the front they
have been deliberately designed to be
traditional appearance and drafts of the
road reflecting the local character most
of the objections focus on highways so
I'll hand over to Dave thank you John
initially I set out in the officers
report there were three issues raised by
the county of our authority in relation
to the access the suitability visibility
splays and the car parking levels on
site the planet was subsequently amended
to provide a wider access to enable two
vehicles to pass and demonstrated the
visibility provided by the development
would be improved competitors its
existing situation by setting back the
buildings compared to the existing
building line of the pub which i think
is shown on the
see the dotted outline there of the
public South information in relation to
local car ownership was extracted from
the census which demonstrated that in
steadily the highest percentage of
properties have on average one car this
is in accordance with the approach that
set out in paragraph 39 of the MPP F in
total as derives a demand for 11 spaces
which the development proposes following
submission of this information here only
outstanding issue was regard to the
management of these spaces with
Warwickshire stated preference being for
all the spaces to be shared and not
allocated which the applicant has
accepted however they're also open to
having the space is allocated on the
basis of the previously mentioned demand
so that prospective purchasers are fully
aware of what spaces they would be
entitled to the exist the issues of
existing residents currently parking on
site that would be displaced has been
raised by third parties
however as I'm sure you're aware the
applicant is currently allowing these
vehicles to park on site 10 seconds and
if they are so minded to they bring
their rights to fence the site off to
prevent people from parking there at
present therefore the displacement of
informal Park and would not be a direct
consequence of the development and its
relevance is somewhat limited ya know
just leaves though thanks for your time
then we're taking questions thank you
very much members any questions raised
as referred to by the parish council of
the problems of Springs at the back of
the building which affecting the Sports
Centre no this was not picked up at all
by the parish council at the time and
it's worth noting that before we
submitted plans formally the applicant
did meet with the Parish Council I just
pick up on the other aspect that has
mentioned about the retaining wall what
your views on plans for that so the rear
of the site yeah we're proposing a
retaining wall obviously it's worth
noting at some point in the past the
existing pub car park has actually been
raised and leveled
which is why there is
step down to the rear garden of the
listed property so the fact that we are
lowering the levels is is bringing it
back down to what it was some historical
point Katherine don't hear you right he
said that cars between parts in the car
park that belong to the local residences
why aren't they Park them on their own
drives the folks re as the photos
demonstrate that it's being used by
looks like some commercial users and
other cars that are parking on the site
so these are the local houses so the
suggestion there would be those
insufficient parking at the local houses
as it is to the inference which suggests
that there's more than one car per
household because I can only issue in
the parking war on their own Drive
there's obviously lots of their car
somewhere else yes south of the the
access and on the road and for the north
or see that the properties don't have on
block parking and the double yellow
lines down the front so I'm sure this is
where they decide to park their cars
again this they have no right to park on
site they just do because they're
allowed to a present okay thank you if
as you say you're only needing one car
per few cars for the the development how
do you expect people to get to work bus
or bicyclists enough employment in the
area under the heading up to ready so
surely there needs more car space the
site's going to provide and secure or
cycle parking which i think is mentioned
in your office's report there is an
hourly bus service going to start from
in to Redditch which calls past the site
so there is an altar there is an
alternative travel choice which again
was replicated and inspectors decision
back in 2014 about to leave in a
sustainable place to live okay thank you
very much
our next speaker is the courage
so just on design the really nice
designs I like them that's that's lovely
I think the parish council do too it's
the right size makes you know we've got
bungalows which is fantastic two bedroom
houses three-bedroom houses brilliant
all right similarly to the parish
council I do have an issue with a step
back there should be a step back I think
for pedestrian safety and an owner a
more pleasant experience than opening
straight onto a narrow pavement right
next to a busy road but that's a minor
issue
my main concern as I stated before his
is parking not yeah okay yes
loads of residents at the moment and
businesses park there they're lighter
partly that's fantastic thank you very
much and we can't say that any
consequence of them not happening that's
relevant but there isn't enough parking
in in the in that road in that area in
nearby roads that you can't park on the
road and you could barely just stop and
have a word with anybody or wait to turn
into to anywhere because it it's
dangerous and and you can't park you
know there's double yellows there's
restrictions so there's loads of cars
which come up are there at the moment I
don't know where they will park when
when this is developing and it will be
developed so so that's fine we accept
that and those people will have to find
somewhere else to park which is fine but
there isn't anywhere to park at the
moment so what has to happen here only
for this develop not for anybody else
this has to has to have a tonne parking
it cannot there's nowhere else to go
except on site for the car parking just
for these houses just for these houses
now I don't know what the standards are
I didn't think we had standards
normally the somewhere else you can park
can park in the road you know you might
not want to but you can park in the road
here
you can't got to be on site so you've
got four houses three-bedroom houses at
the front to say that that's not going
to use two cars at least it's time
support yes you might work even studly
but everyone has a car everyone's good
by this house it's gonna be at least two
people probably with kids and the
three-bedroom houses there's almost
certainly going to be two cars at least
we're not talking about teenagers kids
here okay so two cars that's eight cars
two bedroom houses has three of them at
the back
one car each potentially yeah but
probably to a two bedroom house is going
to be a couple of people they're like
going to have two cars okay bungalows
maybe not maybe elderly people maybe
they've got to the point where they
don't have a car my mom still has a car
she is an elderly person but there we go
let's assume they don't have a car
there's if they're at the point where
they don't have a car they're probably
going to need somebody coming in with a
car to visit them frequently being a
care or relative or whatever so you're
going to need a car parking space anyway
and nobody's mentioned visitors okay
people have visitors there's nine houses
here they were going to be visitors
there's nothing for visitors even with
this incredibly minimum amount okay I
want this place to be developed I like
this this design and whoever it is
they're coming up with good designs but
there's too much on there there's too
much on there for the parking simple as
I kind of you know obviously you know
what I'm saying it's parking just to
summarize this parking thank you
Thank You counselor character I don't
think we need to ask you a question but
anyway thank you very much Katherine
technical questions
Katherine can you give us a little bit
of understanding and clarity about any
guidance that we have over the number of
parking spaces required and unless I'm
mistaken those emerging policy on the
number of car parking spaces yeah we we
don't have an adopted guidance document
that relates to car parking standards
the document we did have was drafted in
around 2007 is now out of date so we can
occasionally refer to it but as I've
said that the guidance with regards to
residential parking standards is out
today since the old SPD has effectively
become unadopted because of the adoption
of the core strategy we now have a
policy that says that Studley is a
sustainable location it's a main rural
center it's a focus of businesses
potentially employment and transport in
the area so there there is an argument
that effectively you can provide less
parking because the site is in a more
sustainable location
there's better access to services
there's less needs to get in a car to
drive somewhere there there isn't any
off street parking on reddit's Road I
have to acknowledge that so it would be
difficult in the event that more cars
will require it but the applicant has
undertaken some work to look at the
numbers of cars that are likely to be
required within this this development
they feel and it's backed up by county
highways that the amount of parking
provision proposed is adequately
given the site location if this was much
more isolated site perhaps we would be
in a better position to argue for a
higher provision of off street parking
but without county backing as offices
it's quite difficult to man that
argument given that the core strategy
categorizes this as a sustainable
location okay absolutely before I say
again County have been known to be wrong
the he referred some guidance it's out
date what did that guidance say so what
number dwelling the the old guidance it
looked at up to three bedrooms Wellings
would have been two off street car
parking spaces plus plus turning I
suppose plus turning areas and third two
beds well up to three bedroom darlings
two spaces so and I think of the RA so
it could be true for all of them really
potentially yeah if the old guidance was
still adopted then yeah we would
probably be asking for our new guidance
as expected when it's not imminent as I
understand it I mean we're talking about
probably a couple of months before it
appears for a public consultation I mean
as officers I don't speak for all
officers but I haven't seen that
guidance myself so I don't know in what
kind of direction that's heading I can't
answer the question with regards to the
refuse vehicles because I think that
that wasn't raised the the access is
existing and they would have already
already been refuse pickups for the
existing pub which I think took place on
reddit's Road so I think County highways
view was that there wouldn't be a
requirement to get a refuse truck into
this site given that the access is
existing and there was an existing
business there
let me try and zoom in a bit on here
because we do have been stores there's a
bin store down nearly access for plots
one to four and another one in the car
park for the rear plots but the one down
by the site access would actually be the
one where the bins would be deposited to
be collected bins have all got to be
moved down onto the road and the lorry
is going to be blocking the road whilst
attempting the bins I would imagine so
but that that's as existing it's no
different to the existing situation I'm
I'm unhappy about the number of car
parking spaces whilst our guidance might
be out today it's the reasonable basis
on which to consider the number of
spaces required clearly we don't meet
that requirement
I would imagine since 2007 the
requirement for cars per household would
have gone up in my view demonstrable but
certainly likely to have gone up so I'm
unhappy with that I also think it's no
Derlin at the site for me that looks
jammed in packed on probably five maybe
six houses might have been more
appropriate so I would be inclined to
refuse the application based on the two
points have made so of doing on the site
and in sufficient parking provision I'd
like to pick up another point that was
raised which is quite I think quite
relevant as well is the fact that the
the building is literally almost on the
road the front of the front doors for
the ones on the reddish road are
literally on to open up onto the road I
would like to see it setback not just
for visibility but from pedestrian
safety as well I think I think sorry but
I think that goes back to the
overdevelopment of site in order to
accommodate a garden a house and
sufficient couple places you've had to
do that in itself I don't think it's a
reason for refusal given that there is a
pub already about that frontage
yeah you're not demonstrably changing
the street scene but I think it would be
preferable to put it back but certainly
our element the site and the provision
of car parking is going back onto the
design on the front doors over some of
the houses actually opening up onto the
street or a zeroth access from the rare
because if this from the front then
you're going to get the problems of
people trying to park in the front of
the building store flowed it will cause
real hazards yep as you can see here
plot one two for the front doors do do
face onto the highway but I mean from my
point of view I think that's an
essential architectural feature it echos
the other dwellings in the area that
front the highway yeah that's top left
so this patio doors in the rear people
usually not keen to walk all the way
around the back going through quickly
and then move on so I believe that the
building should have been moved back I'm
concerned about the bins I agree with
councillor Richard okay right I have a
proposal from Council Richards to refuse
plan permission for this do 2o
development of the site and also parking
concerned insufficient parking and
obviously the concerns have been raised
about the how far fall would be that the
items are the houses on the front there
Polly do I have a seconder for that
all right and bin storage as well and
councillor Rich's do you want to include
something about been destroyed on this
there is been storage I don't think he
said an approach I don't think it's
particularly strong reason to reviews I
think we've got two very strong reasons
already I don't think that particularly
adds anything
there's many the if you wish to include
those if we are going to if the
committee of minds are refused it's been
refused so the bin provision isn't
really an issue when if and when the but
can bring something back I think they're
aware there are issues it would be
helpful to understand whether a refuse
vehicle is going to go into the
development and whether there's
sufficient place to turn but if we're
reducing the size because at the moment
it is over developed as far as I'm
concerned then there'll be more space
like factory with it so members I have a
proposal for a refusal and a seconder
with with that so members the boat
before will you
it's a refused plank mission was
seventeen - OH - 375 sighs for all those
in favor
thank you this committee therefore
resolves to fuse plane from it from 70s
- OH - 375 hushed all thank you may be
rapidly on the next item on the agenda
is 17,000 to double six ones just full
eighteen Moorefield Road Ulster
apologies for having it taken so long
this evening in there to see counselor
it has been a long evening not quite
over yet
so this is our presenting officer when
you're ready
Thank You chairman as members will be
aware a member sightless it took place
this afternoon councilors cargill
courage pain and fielding were in
attendance the application site as
denoted by the black dots in the center
of the plan is located in the town of
Ulster the application site as outlined
in red comprises the dwelling of 18
Moorefield Road and it's residential
curtilage the site is located on a small
Lane within the conservation area this
aerial image shows the application site
in the context of surrounding built form
Planning Commission sought for the
erection of a part 2 Story part single
story extension to the rear of the
dwelling the - section of the building
shows the footprint of the proposed
extension here the existing and proposed
site and rear elevation can be seen an
existing single-story rear extension
would be demolished and in its place a
part 2 Story part single story extension
would be erected the extension would be
constructed in bricks and tiles to match
existing the existing proposed ground
and first floor plans can be seen the
single-story element would extend 0.3
meters in depth when compared to the
existing single-story element whilst the
first-floor element would project 2.1
meters from the existing rear wall of
the dwelling as proposed the three meter
gap between the single-story extension
and ground floor window on the neighbor
at number 16 would remain this photo
shows the rear elevation of the
application dwelling which includes the
existing single-story elements to be
demolished the relationship with the
adjoining neighbor number 20 can be seen
again the single-story extension can be
seen this time in the context of the
side elevation of number 16 Moorefield
Road you can see the first-floor window
and tops of the ground-floor windows
above the boundary treatments and this
photo just shows a clearer image of the
side facing windows in number 16
chairman the recommendation is to
approve the application subject
conditions as detailed within the
committee report thank you thank you
first speaker this evening is Rose Marie
summers
Gary Coxe was going to speak on my
behalf
yes I appreciate that you've got it cold
and I and yes I don't bully how help you
with that thank you very much
so here's your name you my name is Gary
cultural Gary cultural thank you
okay thing Gary in your in time thing
okay the new extension will block light
to the main living room of the
neighborhood's rotaries property the
room is the largest lightest warmest
room in the house it has also been
completely redecorated and furnished as
it is constantly in use the owner son
uses the room for carrying out of his
homework as again it is well lit warm
room the other living room faces
northerly direction and he's cold and a
lot darker moving on parking at the
property to be developed is very limited
there are only there is only really
space of one small car and no room for
more a larger property would attract a
family maybe with a bigger car and they
would not be able to park there often
the current occupiers drive over the
driveway the neighboring property to
access their own driveway this may also
increase the number of vehicles being
brought in to very narrow and poorly lit
cul-de-sac the road to the front of the
property is also very narrow road and it
would be impossible for anyone to park
safely on it outside of the property the
road width will also cause inconvenience
when building materials are delivered
blocking completely all of it
temporarily the road is also too narrow
for a skip and I do not think developers
would get one on the driveway access to
the actual sites that may be developed
is very restricted less than 700
millimeters wide at the narrow
point and shared with the neighboring
house
this gives concern over damage to the
neighboring property during development
if permission were granted the actual
plans on the application show no
measurements at all which made it
difficult for us to see where the
proposed extension will start and end
larger properties are usually associated
with more people ie families therefore
more activity more noise which is not
fitting with the conservation area thank
you
thank you any questions members council
dawn just just one which which houses is
yours the one to another 20 cm between
14 it's okay thanks and can you just go
over how many parking spaces do you have
in your property okay often when I've
been at the property I've been asked to
move my vehicle so that they can access
their driveway which means they are
actually cutting across the driveway and
number 16 and that tiny little smallish
and I noticed on the other [ __ ] thing
that particular slide of the rear view
of the existing properties that's it
there
I noticed that extension there which is
basically I think what the applicant is
proposing but on this side of it does
that have any impact on your light into
your your property at the moment all
right any other questions thank you very
much
right annex speaker then yes thank you
is Jonathan abate the applicant
Thank You Jonathan you have three
minutes in your own time
[Music]
basically I've owned the property for
about 11 years when we bought the
property we did a little cosmetic
makeover currently we've got some rising
damp issues in the single-story kitchen
which we proposed to be demolished as
part of the and obviously kill two birds
with one stone basically by doing a
small extension it all came about is the
property next door did a beautiful
extension all in keeping with the
character of the existing property
obviously we we during that property
because it's to seventies and we thought
they did such a lovely job we applied
for permission they didn't have any
trouble we've we put a planning
application in we withdrew it because
haven't spoken to the case officer we
were bought it was brought to our where
that we were potentially blocking the
light of the property so we amended all
the drawings we've scaled it right back
to much smaller still enhance the
character of the building that's about
it really we've tried to address the
concerns of the neighbors we certainly
don't cause any destruction to them
whatsoever
if we if permission is granted we'll
just get one where they'd get the job
done and leave the tenants that live in
the property that I've lived there for
ten years you know leave everybody happy
hopefully get clear off
we have other skip on the drive before
now they're doing it is just about it is
very twice you know
the existing police never complain
there's ever been any sort of parking
issues straight on the frame because
they thank you please try menacing Thank
You Emma so any questions you'd like to
ask
no thank you well thank you very much
indeed thank you
right open different technical questions
also he can open first I apologize to
counsel vain
chairman and members of the rest area
Planning Committee
I recognize that the applicant has
submitted amended plans and that the
Town Council has removed its objection
which I must admit I'm disappointed in
but in my opinion the extensions to
number 18
morphia Road would still have an
overbearing effect on the neighboring
property this being on number 16 or V
Road and would have a detrimental effect
on their living conditions this is the
reason why I have maintained my
objection and why I requested a site
visit so that members of the committee
could see for themselves how cramped the
area is more via Road is a very narrow
road without pavements known as the
sample a substantial property
immediately opposite number 16
Moorefield Road which makes the front
living room there of number 16 dark and
cold owing to the fact it gets very
little or no sunlight throughout the day
so the family tend to live in the middle
room as it is the lightest round floor
living room in the house
owing to the fact that it gets sunlight
during the day as there is one good
sliced window in the room these are the
reasons the family and I have concerns
regarding the proposed extensions to
number 18 as they would happen of
overbearing effect on number 16 as our
is only a narrow gap between the
properties and the extensions would have
an effect on the middle living room by
blocking the light therefore affecting
the family's quality of life with regard
to the extension on number 20 I this is
one of the reasons why I wanted the site
visit today it's a nice extension but it
doesn't interfere with anybody else
because it it's next to a row of garages
and a drive to the garages so doesn't
affect any of the property other than
garages which you know I don't think as
you can't compare the two so therefore I
ask that you refuse this application and
thank you I thank you that just I'm at
your last point if the sunlight is gonna
get blocked going into number sixteen
from an extension to number eighteen
surely the Sun Direction is coming from
there and the same impact will be had on
eighteen so there would be an impact
here almost exactly the same in fact I'm
confused by the window number sixteen is
facing straight along that way and
there's gonna be a double extension and
the single extension right in front of
their window
chairman would it help if we looked at
the layout plan so that you can see the
path of the Sun as it moves across the
day so you can see when it's shining in
that window when it isn't so my cursor
is following the line of the Sun thank
you any other questions
oh okay
technical questions then thank you very
much casa it's an idea of the sight
lines from number 16 out or from how
it's gonna impact have you got you there
25 degrees in there 45 degrees that's in
terms of the first law window I think
you can see there quite clearly that the
extension has been kept within it in
terms of the ground floor window we have
carried out the twenty five degree line
from the center point of it and it isn't
breached by the single story element
which is obviously the element of the
extension which is in front of that
window referring to the 20 opportunities
next door one this extension seems to be
higher than the one in that it's kind of
cover up that window on the right-hand
side whereas on the 20s it comes to just
below the windowsill well yes there is
also an extension coming back from
number sorry yes I misread the plaque
neither photograph my expert counselor
beside me is too pointed out that
that's fine thank you any other
questions no okay I shall open up a
debate so given where we are with number
20 it does look like a very attractive
extension actually I think this number
18 would benefit from the same thing and
we clearly our case officer has gone to
great lengths to understand exactly what
the impact is from the directions of Sun
from 25 degree angles all the other bits
and pieces and this extension meets the
criteria I can see no planning reason
why we would refuse it so I would
propose we go with the officers
recommendation and grant security yeah I
think if I hadn't got on the side visit
I say exactly the same I think the
extension itself as proposed would look
lovely it's a nice idea I've got nothing
against the two-story element either
because that I think doesn't affect too
negatively the neighbors it's the new
single storey but there's an existing
single storey bit which will be largely
replace that won't change but then it
comes out further so that what you see
now has the Sun roomie thing which is
quite see-through frankly would have a
roof put on top of top of it and be
solid when you sit when you're standing
in that lounge as we did next door and
you look out at the moment
it's constrained there's a lot of
building you can see from it but if you
imagine this extra building going on top
of it then you go down from a situation
where you can see sea sky and Sun in the
winter and trees when that's in there
it'll it'll it'll take out all the view
of the trees which you can see it'll
take out the winter sunshine as it would
as it would have been today not the
summer sunshine it will have a big
effect on on that room and that is the
only window of that
and I think in this case it is
overbearing I said I would
I was recommend actually refusal feeling
having been on the side visit as well
the extent the height of the extension
is any about half a meter higher than me
no the back extension is only half a
meter than the existing the ridge height
of the proposed extension is 5
centimeters higher than the Ridge height
at that point obviously it will be
higher inevitably where it's coming back
Richard thanks so clarity points I think
first of all the what how much taller is
the new proposed than the bit that's
sticking out now and how much longer and
what you're looking for that the second
question is under permitted development
rights would the occupant be able to do
that minor extension anyway
the kick-out bit not the two-story bit
put your no pressure isn't
I think in terms of PD we don't really
have enough information in front of us
to be able to confirm that it would be
acceptable that it would comply with
British development regulations because
there's a bit of a question as to
whether this element here is original or
not if this element is original then
they could well do the existing
projection and a permitted development
if it's not then they wouldn't be able
to enter permissive element but they can
tend to do it and a prior approval so
it's getting more complicated in terms
of the the heights so the existing is
3.5 meters high and as proposed it's
three point five five meters high so
five centimeters and in terms of depth
it's coming out zero point three meters
more than the existing conservatory but
obviously as I said earlier the height
over the conservatory is obviously
higher than existing I have to agree the
the existing extension just looked
really nice and I can't disagree with
that I think it's been merged in
beautifully into the existing building
and it must make a very nice extension
to that one unfortunately like us as the
councillors and their pain said it's on
a effectively The Blind Side there's
nothing there on this side standing in
their living room it really will be
overbearing in this particular case and
I'm struggling I'm struggling with this
one because it's on the one hand I think
it'll be a lovely extension I really do
think that but on the other hand I think
it will definitely impact the immunity
of the residents at 16 so I'm really
struggling on this one and I'm afraid I
can't support it under those
circumstances castlelong
thank you chair um yeah it's it's very
tricky and whilst I do feel sympathy for
the neighbors and there's the light
issue I this could happen under
permitted development in my view and I
think the officer is completely correct
in in in looking at this in the round
and and finding no reason for refusal
because I can't find any reason for
brutal so I would propose that we accept
this application
given I've already made a proposal I'm
going to ask counselor and if that was a
seconder it's all my proposal I agree
you did for those at first I agree with
that and council Orton is going to
second okay members there call the vote
before you is to grant a planning
permission for 1702 double six 1/4 all
those in favor against this committee
therefore resolves to grant planning
permission for 1702 double six once
multiple thank you
we're moving rapidly on to our last item
this evening thank you for bearing with
us the item is 17 slash double 3/8 to
slash AMD which must stand for amendment
thank you good on getting good and
elizabeth is our presenting officer
Thank You Javon the application site as
you know is Elizabeth house which is
located in the centre of Stratford just
to give you a bit of context permission
was approved earlier in there for the
construction of a new entrance door to
the building this application seeks a
non-material amendment providing steps
to the front instead of a level access
disabled access would still be available
via the main entrance into Elizabeth
house and just a couple of photos of the
sections of building which is in
questions it's this area here where you
may have seen work going on and here is
a photo of another entrance door into
Elizabeth house showing the staff which
is similar to that proposed chairman the
recommendation is to approve the
applications subject to conditions as
detail no conditions chairman the
regulations to approve the application
as Perth
it's council factory in the room wants
to speak on this
okay Emmett okay then one technical
question please that's it no members we
propose that we go and I will send
members the vote before used to grant
plaintiff thank you
your own commission for 17 such owed
double 382 such AMD all those in favor
thank you would you therefore resolves
to grant plankton which is some tea sir
Oh double 3:18 and good night and thank
you very much indeed no other business